[Musique]
la radio a le truc mais oui ce matin je
suis allé au précis m'attends à rien on
parlait aussi mieux ce soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle
émission pas comme les autres vous
connaissez le principe tout le monde en
parle alors tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez des qui voici landa
fille
[Applaudissements]
cannes accueille laurent comment ça va
ça va très très bien j'étais un petit
peu occupé par les répètes de ma pièce
j'ai pas le temps de préparer
ouais mais bon j'ai pris la doc jem ont
signé un peu sur laon
d'abord je voudrais remercier d'abord
tous les téléspectateurs qui sont devant
leur téléviseur ce soir c'est très sympa
mais surtout tous ceux qui étaient là
lundi soir pour voir ça s'en va et ça
revient qui était donc ma première
émission en première partie de soirée
vous étiez 5 millions à regarder cette
émission merci courage a continué alors
évidemment mais aussi chez sita un
deuxième set d'or ça te faire des prêts
ce livre c'est quoi le rsa aide à sa
bibliothèque beaucoup d'e-mails
concernant laurent baffie comment lutter
contre le mouvement baptiste un email de
patrick gomez est une très bonne idée qu
il dit si laurent baffie bouge pas d'un
jingle il faut que serge le réalisateur
le gel je laisse ça veut dire figé liger
banc d'essai et la serre ges qu'on peut
figer laurent baffie pourvoir aux miss
fiche tout seul ce connard
tu vois là d'un côté tu me vois le côté
du lit ce connard beaucoup disaient
c'est ça que les gens ont du mal à
comprendre
j'ai beaucoup dit mais aussi de suisse
qui n'en parle jamais des suisses est
vrai qu'on parle rarement des suisses
ici ils demandent 10 secondes de silence
pour les suissesses que vous êtes
d'accord pour faire 10 secondes de
silence en l'honneur des suisses n'ont
personne n'est d'accord je suis désolé
frédéric du voisin personnes le faire
dix secondes de silence pour les suis
ensuite des emails de singapour c'est
incroyable ingénieux une mission
internationale
elle est regardée à singapour donc où
l'émission est censuré pourquoi c'est
parce que la cause était question un peu
trop à la has caused avec singapour est
un état très prude et puis de haïti
aussi donc il ya des gens qui regardent
cette émission haïti voilà c'était les
nouvelles de la semaine on passe au
sommaire mise à part laurent baffie je
recevrai ce soir pierre arditi
dutronc
jean marie messier est ce que
garou
fabrice tiozzo
et marco de grève est là
[Applaudissements]
très beau programme ce soir
très beau programme lesquels il va
maintenant qu'ils aillent oui j'ai
bouquiner un petit peu parce que ça fait
pas pro quand on n'a pas travaillé assez
clair donc avant que la vita riches a
fait ça pendant le magnéto qui vient si
vous voyez l'accord 1 puisque comme vous
le savez une tradition dans cette
émission qui consiste à rediffuser les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé
magnéto serge vous savez que naomi
campbell ne parlent pas bien le français
ont beau avoir recours à une traductrice
et nous avons la chance d'avoir ce soir
parmi nous belinda bonsoir belinda
bonsoir andré leon talley dit en parlant
de vous naomi campbell un fessier si
haut si stable si ferme qu'on pourrait
poser une flûte de champagne dessus est
utilisé comme table à cocktail essayons
ce soit est ce qu'on peut nous apporter
du sang vous avez choisi ou pas
ok c'est le vieux où le bret on admet
m'acheter lourde quand on voit tous ces
tops models anorexique et quand on sait
ce qu'on les paye on se dit que ça fait
cher le kilo et vous avez connu beaucoup
d'hommes orson welles c'est vrai qu'il
voulait que vous quittiez tout pour le
suivant l'amérique c'est pas vrai
là c'est pas vrai quel beau rohr sept
ans m'a déjà après il m'a dit j'étais
amoureux fou de toi je n'étais pas à
perdre avant et vous l'a dit après oui
est ce que vous préférez attention c'est
très grave mais un mec qui bosse bien
mais qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui bosse
mâles mais les fidèles
nina millotte ah bon j'en cherchais un
troisième a oui les fidèles on vous a
marié un peu comme jeanne moreau déjà
parce que tous les hommes qu'on vous a
attribué vous n'avez pas eu
obligatoirement non mais il ya comme un
peu oublié son verre non mais si vous
buvez tu vas connaître ses pensées
bassila j'ai dis moi ce que tu dis moi
ce qu'elle pense on me dit mon dieu mon
dieu mais des histoires je peux je paye
ses combattants allez savoir plus et les
pensées de cadres c'est à dire je
n'arrive pas dire un truc drôle les bons
gestes
[Musique]
g
ouais bravo aux publié la machine à
trahir chez denoël attention faites par
une variante moi je fais des moulinets
en même temps vous me permettrait d'être
indiscipliné comme je le suis dans
d'autres enceintes interne à la rebelle
c'est un punk bon il a publié un livre
belinda ces votes jingle chaque fois où
viendraient dans cette émission il y
aura sa voir belinda
[Applaudissements]
harley et vous pouvez le voir sur de
nombreuses chaînes en ce moment voilà
alors ça fait un bouton l'a pas vu il a
choisi tout le monde en parle pour
parler de son retour sur les planches
parisiennes
ça sera après noël ça s'appellera
joyeuses pâques voici pierre arditi
non bâti tfb j'ai un dossier sur pierre
à la vache bien vous êtes né à paris le
1er décembre 1944 ont traîné passation
enfin bon je vais pourquoi tu as un
dinosaure tiré sur ton assez parce que
c'est mon fils gaston il me dit toujours
papa dans l'émission les vaches mmm n ya
pas de dinosaures n'ont donc maintenant
j'ai un dinosaure pour gaston voilà tu
fais bien qui rit c'est bien c'est une
addition c'est même des dinosaures alors
impunity ça fait une paye qu'on vous a
pas vu c'est quand même temps vous
appelez la télé ben je sais pas ça fait
peut-être un an et demi un an et demi
c'est ça vous avez pas changé c'est
toujours aussi élégant il vous trouvez
david ailleurs les prix d'élégance
monsieur longines à une grande soirée au
ritz a fait deuxième
oui mais ils ont tous les deux viennent
d'ailleurs et l'a compris un truc arditi
ont ils s'habillent en ardisson il a un
prix d'élégance
c'est facile se répètent le contraire
non mais c'est le contraire plus vieux
mais beaucoup plus en temps je m'habille
comme ça l'année prochaine je me dirai
en arditi j'aurais élégance pendant
molière et le poids comment ça va vous
n'êtes pas grossir sa ba écoute et je
n'ai pas dites moi non sa valeur d'un
visage ou bien doit pas le reste mais le
visage est bien là non c'est pas mal
hein franchement là c'est bien le
maintien la rédaction mais je vous
regarde moi beaucoup le savent et je
regarde toi ô baisser puisque le
problème en fait c'est ça et ça je le
vois que vous vous n'avez absolument
rien si j' avais si je mets profil c'est
tout
alors donc vous êtes en tournée en
france c'est pour ça qu'on voit pas
beaucoup à la télé parce que vous
travaillez vraiment sérieusement la très
sérieuse très sérieusement depuis
combien de temps vous êtes en tournée
avec joyeuse ça le troisième mois à oui
alors joyeuses pâques donc mais c'est
une pièce de jean poiret évidemment on
va en parler tout de suite mais d'abord
vous savez il ya un petit rituel dans
cette émission c'est comment on fait
voilà les plus grands acteurs le fond je
dis ça pour arnaud montebourg qui n'a
pas voulu faire voilà à pierre arditi
qu'un grand comédien français le énorme
il levait bah voila c'est du lourd là
quand et comment il le fait bien
alors c'est à partir du 16 janvier 2001
au théâtre des variétés mises en scène
de votre ami bernard murat avec caroline
silhol et barbara schulz est le signe
d'une comédie de jean poiret je vais
raconter
le pitch si vous voulez oui c'est tout
moi ce qui est bien avec moi fait le
pitch yves la différence avec d'autres
animateurs c'est que vous êtes obligés
d'aller vendre votre pièce par exemple
moi je fais tout sauf montebourg il a
failli était gentil je vais pas vendu
son vieux alors c'est ce fil qui est
jouée par caroline silhol donc qui part
pour le week end de pâques et stéphane
c'est vous son mari en profite pour
inviter une jeune fille qui s'appelle
julie est joué par barbara schulz mais
il ya des grèves d'avion c'est drôle
comme c'est une vraie comédie à la
feydeau à cette histoire
et alors elle revient elle revient ainsi
à elle revient et elle trouve son mari
stéphane vous avec la jeune fille
voilà et qu'est ce que vous dites à ce
moment là qu'est ce que vous faites à ce
moment là et bien à ce moment là
j'explique avec un aplomb absolument
colossal que c'est ma fille
voilà d'un premier lit d'un premier lit
voilà un cd en suit une fois que le
doigt et mis dans cet engrenage là c'est
à dire dans ce dans ce début de
mensonges
il pousse le mensonge jusqu'à la folie
qui l'emmènera jusqu'à la folie c'est un
petit peu le mécanisme du tailleur pour
dames qui est aussi l'histoire d'un
menteur qui se fait vous avez joué aussi
oui je sais jouer absolument ya quinze
ans maintenant spécialisé dans tout ça
ça me plaît bien mais cela vous
sérieusement vous passez de beckett
assez d'eau assez facilement
moi je pense que mon métier c'est de
jouer tout se sait pas jouer tout c'est
de jouer les auteurs qui sont dignes de
ce nom espoir est aussi digne d'être
joué que beckett que guitry que fait
donc le grimbert que yasmina reza que
tout le reste c'est malin alors donc ça
commence le 16 janvier au théâtre des
variétés qui appartient à jean paul
belmondo ou jean paul
si l'on regarde bien joué le rôle est
il agit aussi bien ce qu'il a fait mieux
c'est dans une ambiance laisser
tranquille on était en paix là c'est pas
le meilleur film de belmondo on peut le
dire ou c'est tabou c'est tabou alors
c'est un excellent film pour la
télémaintenance et verrouiller un vieux
attention alors vous le principe de
votre jeu d'acteur c'est cette puiser en
vous à travers des expériences
personnelles pour les retranscrire sur
scène ou à l'écran et des fois c'est des
choses très privé dont vous nourrissez
vos personnages vous faites appel à
votre mémoire affective c'est ça c'est
votre façon de huy pas mon métier
d'acteur oui pas seulement enfin vous
savez c'est ce qu'on appelle la méthode
stanislavski n est oui alors je le dis à
nos amis téléspectateurs c'est de
service public vous allez voir
stanislavski acteur et metteur en scène
russe 1863 1938 animateurs du théâtre
d'art de moscou 0-1 indice est donc là
les metteurs en scène d'antoine tchekhov
entre autres est bon et je sais pas ma
méthode à moi c'est que je crois pour le
vivre maintenant depuis 35 ans que
finalement on ne fait que jouer des
petits morceaux de soi même au fur à
court des personnages qu'on est con
naissance et interprété tout au long
d'une vie
alors évidemment le but c'est de prendre
à l'intérieur de soi des choses qu'on
peut connaître et de la mettre au
service de quelqu'un qui n'est pas soi
voilà il faut très longtemps pour un
pour le comprendre et deux pour savoir
le faire assez vite séchées comment il
fallait
et quand on joue une pièce qu'ils ne
correspond à rien de ce qu'on a vécu y'a
rien qui ne correspond pas justement ça
n'existe pas il ya toujours un moment
prendre comme ça ok pierre ça veut dire
que vous ai jamais vécu comme j'ai fait
là parce que la socgen est arrivé vous
de tromper votre femme pendant ça m'est
arrivé de mentir
l'arrivée de mme antier mais c'est ici
qu'est une manière de mentir par exemple
kiné qui pourrait par un certain instant
ma véhémence peut me servir de vérité
par exemple comme souvent chez les gens
qui manquent donc je me sers de cette
véhémence dans le mensonge pour nourrir
ce personnage qui lui est pratiquement à
mende
acculé être un menteur professionnel
comme ça je peux le trouver chez moi est
ce qu'on va passer des choses plus plus
intimes
elle le sait
vine briques ce que vous avez déjà été
mariée que j'ai déjà été mariée vous
avez un enfant quoi le sait que sanaa
mais qui est ce garçon mais qu'il est
évidemment sinon on le sait maintenant
et ben ça c'est sûr oui là parce que
j'essayais de comprendre que vous avez
pu vous mettre dans la peau de stéphane
en fait si vous êtes arrivé cette
histoire vous avez un enfant avant votre
mariage il peut revenir alors il m'est
arrivé à une certaine époque d'être
obligé de mentir pour des raisons comme
celle-là oui sans pour autant faire
passer la jeune fille en question pour
ma fille bien sûr alors ni pour ta mère
rassurante en moi alors il une bonne
nouvelle donc d'abord il ya évidemment
les variétés le 16 janvier puis ensuite
le 5 juillet vous fait l'ouverture du
festival d'avignon dans la grande cour
mais fait pas à le blasé comme ça ça je
suis amusé à beaucoup oui oui surtout
que c'est l'école des femmes qe2 voilà
bien le rhinathiol à susurrer des fois
il vaut quoi que ce soit corniche en
faire une émission culturelle donc vous
jouez arnolphe évidemment évidemment
vous avez un succès tardif
oui hein vous trouvez vous par rapport à
jordy oui c'est vrai mais c'est pas mal
d'ailleurs évitant de vous construire
c'est le temps de vous aimer avant j'ai
fait mon métier je me suis construit je
me suis identifié moi je pense la
première premier devoir est le premier
travail d'un acteur c'est d'abord savoir
qui il est bon de pouvoir reproduire les
autres bon tout ce temps là m'a servi à
ça ça m'a servi à vivre c'est-à-dire à
constituer un morceau de vie et de ma
vie qui me sert aujourd'hui de matériau
de travail quand je quand je vois ce que
je viens à peine 20 ans et puis voilà
c'est pas venu c'est pas venu d'un coup
pourtant vous êtes allés au spectacle à
ces jeunes si dans le monde du spectacle
assez jeune et puisque votre père était
peintre ils paient toujours une ville
est toujours et toujours vivant mais pas
jeunes du temps non il a 86 ans mais bon
le salut si tu me regardes arrive à nous
regarde et nous regardent ça lui papa
bon anniversaire voilà
alors vous viviez dans une grande maison
rue des rues des martyrs
ben oui et plein de monde et c'est lui
vous a poussé vers un métier créatif
votre père ça c'est rare parce que vous
dites avec lui était pas question d'être
fonctionnaire ou ingénieur oui ce qui
était encore plus rare à l'époque
aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
devenu à la mode tous les tous les
gamins ont envie de devenir chanteur
acteur à l'époque c'était pas très bien
vu alors en plus votre famille vous si
tu as fait tes cousins avec les cannetti
il ya un prix nobel chez les cannes et
immédiate ici oui absolument
les nobel de littérature en littérature
à l'écrivain mission culturelle
donc je quality oui jacques canetti
qu'avec découvreur de tout le monde
oui qui avait un endroit absolument
formidable qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui
que celle qui s'appelait les trois
baudets l'abonné ou j'ai vu moi débuté
petit garçon moi petit hérisson
gainsbourg brel
fernand raynaud raymond devos bon
s'était formée à la vaysse est tombé à
me souviens très bien de ces quinze
jours la première fois où j'étais à
l'époque quand même un vrai choc mais il
a été vu il était absolument magnifique
il avait les cheveux tout à ferrat avait
complètement ton du haras il avait ses
grandes oreilles en chou-fleur
je me souviendrai toute ma vie il avait
un magnifique costume prince de galles
avec un col roulé gris perle et des
pompes pointues en daim et des dandys
déjà en titre et dont il était
absolument magnifique et chantait
génialement et un jour votre père veut
dire regarde ce type et des formidables
et c'était raymond devos
voilà c'est raymond devos j'ai été
nourri au lait du spectacle vraiment
rebih brauner sa première sortie au
théâtre de pierre arditi à l'âge de 7
ans on comprend tout après comédie
française au poulailler et c'est tout
binger c'est tout neuf ça m'intéresse
et ça m'intéresse c'est vraiment les
gens sont devenus ce qu'ils sont travail
bien et alors vous voyez amphitryon avec
hélène perdriel robert esche
quand on voit ça à l'âge de 7 ans sa
marque sa marque pour toujours après
vous appris votre boulot chez tania
balachova et maréchal évidemment et au
cinéma aussi ça arrive assez tardivement
la reconnaissance non oui s'ils
tentaient d'ailleurs qu'elle soit pour
être tout à fait sincère véritablement
arrivé aujourd'hui je ne crois pas
vraiment avec tous les films de rennes
et que vous avez vous et oui voilà même
s'est montré mon grand titre de gloire
je suis très heureux je pense tout de
même qu'il ya quelque chose au cinéma
qui qui me reste encore à faire
et si ça se fait maintenant lieu ça ne
se fait pas tant pis je peux trouver ma
carrière me suffit telle qu'elle est
passé utilisée au cinéma c'est un peu ce
que vous dites là un peu et en tout cas
pas forcément comme il faudrait
m'utiliser marc dorcel c'est une ouvre
la voie il ya des morts celui ya des
morts celui qui n'ont pas encore été
vraiment rentrés au cinéma c'est
lamentable
c'est là vraiment lamentable et je
dirais que le tueur est libre ça m'a
rendu ma fille est beaucoup beaucoup là
dessus
c'est sa vision libérale de la tellette
c'est une façon de mater la révolution
à
alors là attention vous savez qu'on va
faire une petite interview mensonge
cet objet vous qui dit toujours la
vérité et puis c'est en liaison avec la
pièce joyeuse parade on est obligé de
mentir vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas
pendant le djing
[Musique]
vous avez cligner de l'oeil à finasser
possible vous le dire officiellement de
boycotter ce cérémonial stupide et
injustifiée voilà c'est ma position je
les ai joués viendrait
ces droits
bien alors politiquement quel que soit
votre fidélité à vos engagements de
jeunesse
on vous a beaucoup vu ces derniers temps
en compagnie d'alain madelin et vous
avez déclaré d'ailleurs moi un type dans
le programme politique et d'enlever sa
cravate
ça me va vous lui trouvez quoi ma de la
ba hmad là je trouve qu'il a il a un
discours qui est particulièrement
adaptée à l'époque dans laquelle nous
vivons et je trouve qu'il ya une
modernité est une espèce de fraternité
qui émane de ce discours qui à mon sens
devrait rassembler pratiquement toutes
les couches sociales de la nation c'est
pour cela d'ailleurs que je vous le
voyez mais honnêtement je le vois à
juste titre d'ailleurs candidat à la
présidence de la république et j'ai la
ferme intention
et c'est parce que madelin a enlevé sa
cravate que vous ne portez plus de
cravate c'est une sorte de mamie c'est
là une sorte de mimétisme les maîtres du
troisième millénaire
on admirait canton estime quelqu'un dont
on a envie de lui ressembler c'est un
peu comme pour vous tirez vous vous êtes
mis au sport fait du vélo avec drucker
tous les dimanches matins avec michel
drucker s'espacent commencé sans ça ça
se passe pas bien pour lui parce qu'il a
un mal de chien à deux chiffres non je
suis très très entraînés ça fait des
années et des années que je [ __ ] mais
sens du terme d'ailleurs et lui pour le
moment ils pédalent plutôt dans la
choucroute c'est à dire que il nous est
arrivé d'ailleurs il n'ya pas très
longtemps d'être filmé par ses petits
copains de la 2 et c'était très
emmerdant parce que j'étais obligé de
j'étais obligé de pédaler dans le vide
pour qu'ils puissent me rattraper
contador beaucoup il dort énormément il
s'économise énormément et je ne sais pas
il ya quelques jours et quelques jurons
mais peut-être que finalement là alors
il est beaucoup plus âgée que moi à
drucker et donc c'est là où au fond
c'est là la différence pour le téléthon
avait fait 5 fois le tour du
périphérique en vélo 8 et admiratif x 8
x 8 x 10 7 minutes 46 secondes 4/6 alors
l'une des raisons de votre forme c'est
pierre aboutissent et que vous avez
laissé tomber la drogue d'une façon à
peu près complète sauf les pétards mais
enfin bon ouais une dizaine de pétards
par jour parce que ça remplace ses
cigarettes on faisait arrêter des
cigarettes dont vous êtes obligé de
fumer des pétards pas de pas disent tout
de même déjà bien un parseur du
périphérique voilà et vous avez retrouvé
votre légendaire énergie sexuelle qui a
fait votre succès faut bien le dire bien
d'autres talents pierre mais ya pas que
ça non plus alors b d'ailleurs grâce à
dieu il y avait cette énergie sexuelle
sinon je serais absolument pas là où je
suis aujourd'hui voilà que pierre a
retrouvé en arrêtant l'adoption
d'énergies sexuelle on vous a beaucoup
vu cet été avec linda hardy à saint
tropez
oui et les doctrines de l'aveyron
remords il y avait nagui avec une blonde
décolorée arthur avec une zone de forêts
et pierre arditi avec bolloré brûlera
défi qui a démarré en tant l'amour à
mary bale donc c'est vraiment cool
à son honneur qu'elle ne sait pas ce
qu'il va jouer si vous voulez haute
maribel chili tient alors oui marine
rima rebelles n'est pas courant c'est la
petite oui mais lier à dammarie d'elle
on l'applaudît
c'est joli gaston il a un autre
dinosaure il s'appelle mary bale voilà
j'ai quand on est enfant va grandir et
qui va te dire papa ya pas assez de buts
sur le plateau que tu vas faire quoi
concrètement je vais faire revenir
donc oui retournez-les en ce moment avec
joyeuses pâques en province il paraît
que c'est surtout la tournée des boîtes
échangistes
c'est à dire que si vous voulez ça fait
quand même une bonne dizaine d'années
que un peu plus même douzaine d'années
gilbert barbier m'avait dit que qu'au
fond sa clientèle son public on le
fabrique qu'en province
et j'ai suivi ce conseil à la lettre et
c'est d'ailleurs blier lui-même qui
m'avait dit que je pouvais justement en
profiter voilà l'avantagé des tournées
c'est sa fille voilà et donc ça fait une
bonne douzaine d'années maintenant que
je fais plus grande est un nom de boîte
échangiste vous donnerai des adresses
les intéressera sûrement dahlane
ex-homme d'affaires ils se connaissent
j'ai l'intention d'éditer un guide audio
il ya le mardi 8 et joe g d'ici des
boîtes échangistes le arditi avec 1h
heard it is the hard way vous êtes
choqué beaucoup de monde quand même avec
votre mercedes vitres fumées sur la roue
et vous fait allumer des cigarettes par
les assistants vous trouvez pas que
c'est un peu too much mais vous savez
moi je vais vous dire quand on a réussi
après tous ces mois à 1 quand on a du
pognon
quand on a du mal et on sait bien dans
les clubs où ces maisons qu'à se
démerder pour faire les mêmes choses
on reconnait on reconnaît vraiment le
may be missed le choc
le libéral le libéral de choc alors ben
on va terminer avec la littérature et
des lectures publiques aussi dans les
villes où vous vous allez utiliser du
renaud camus vous lisez du robert
brasillach du nietzsche oui bah c'était
gelé je n'ai découvert sur le tard et je
dois dire que j'ai eu tort
ouais c'est un manque de culture de ma
pas très bon ce qui là encore il ya une
parole importante à proférer aujourd'hui
il ya une pensée que qu'on ne partage
pas suffisamment et en particulier dans
les couches basses de la société qu'ils
ne le disent pas comme tout le monde le
sait et je voudrais être le le chant
profond de cette parole vous la tendance
à atteindre et je ne vois pas pourquoi
elle voulait de lecture de brasillach
sont remarquables et voilà oui
l'antisémitisme ça vous choque plus du
tout un fût un temps où ça vous énervez
maintenant vous vivez avec ben qu'est ce
que vous voulez normalement c'est dans
l'air du temps alors après tout pourquoi
pas hein
voilà pierre dit merci
et voici maintenant qu'on est belle qui
pensent en simple
audrey marnay
non monsieur
on se calme je les hais ce que tu as mal
je l'est pas c'est que vous n'avez pas
de fissure humains non je l'est pas
c'est pas l'émission de la semaine
prochaine la belle-fille qu'essaye de
bosser oui là qu'est ce qu'on fait en
chêne bien audrey bonsoir vers vous a
permis à côté de n'importe qui c'est un
des hommes les plus séduisants de notre
pays
pierre arditi qui est de nouveau en
ville vous avez 20 ans depuis deux mois
oui vous me jurez ahmad 75g pas le poids
le poids on est à peu près 50 parce que
j'en avoir un petit bébé ya pas
longtemps que la db que ses geôliers
n'est pas le cas vous avez retrouvé
votre poids votre poids d'avant de
taille d'abord je vous dis c'est pas mal
il ya deux mois on l'appelait valérie
bénaïm et là tu as vu quand on termine
avec les mensurations 81 64 e 25 les
spécialistes apprécieront un stylo 118
ne peut pas lutter alors on peut rien
faire dont vous êtes l'un des top
modèles les plus demandés dans le monde
vous faites des défilés des photos pour
les plus grandes marques je peux pas les
citer évidemment parce que c'est le
service public
il ya beaucoup de grandes marques on
chérit généraux que des trucs
prestigieux jamais de la croix de sang
mais camembert et tout ça mais camembert
les trucs je trouve l affiche
j'aime pas travailler comme ça ça fait
amateur tout fait pour cela et qu'il a à
benjamin castaldi
non je tamponne
bien un don vous faites j'ai dit dès
défiler les photos pour les plus grandes
dates vous refuser d alcool 1 oui les
pubs d'alcool les pubs de tabac la
fourrure pascal beaucoup de mannequins à
un moment qui ont dit on fait plus des
pubs de foule puis maintenant les
histoires venues quand même je lai quand
la mode
quand la mode de la quand la mode de la
fourrure est revenue audrey je l'aï sont
tous trois mis pardon lors elle est
mannequin et préciser ça au départ
j'étais mannequin donc la fourrure
programme refuser la fourrure qui voit
dans toutes les mains mannequin refonder
pu courir bah oui ce qui est un peu
triste pour les animaux mais bon c'est
une mode c'est toujours l'allemagne de
la vraie fourrure et sans déconner ça
fait quand même un nom et ça fait un an
que j'ai c'est de lutter avec toutes les
maisons qui font la fourrure donc ce qui
fait qu'il ya des défilés où on ne peut
pas me voir parce qu'il ya trop de
fourrures et les clients pressés
mobilité vraiment quoi servait la vie de
2,3 fouine bladou hermine c'est
qu'effectivement on peut dire qu'une
femme qui portait un manteau de fous
rires ça fait ça fait but ça fait but
dégoûté 1
donc voilà
[Applaudissements]
laissez parler ou l'aurait laissée par
les audrey qui est mannequin je suis pas
brigitte bardot non plus mais je trouve
ça un peu triste du d'utiliser les
animaux alors qu'on n'a pas vraiment
besoin encore je comprendre les pays
très froid qui les utilisent
mais on être une mode sexy de bardos qui
est bizarre à comprendre c'est qu'elle
défend les animaux elle attaque les
arabes feraient mais de faire là
alors loria autre chose il ya autre
chose c'est que vous c'est que vous
refusez de poser nue j'ai commencé à
travailler j'avais
vraiment 16 ans et à 16 ans tu avais des
trucs à montrer mais si c'est une
bouteille ou tonnes ccf de douala
à 16 ans on n'a pas envie de poser nue
là j'en ai 20 vous êtes d'accord
non donc vous avez gagné les top models
98 autres au fait de la mode et c'est
entre deux ans si 18 ans
[Musique]
non plus
je
[Musique]
et
alors afin que c'est mademoiselle au des
marchés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
ceux qui m'ont aidé mon agent silva et
ça ils sont
car et tous les gens qui m'ont soutenu
depuis le début merci à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et de la main en 1998 au fait de la mode
on va voir bientôt sur une chaîne
concurrente de villars contente oui et
même les églises de la mode aussi vous
en 97 et venus de la prune sont je vous
dis tout moi vous me demandez si des cas
vous avez des souvenirs on va y arriver
le nom de votre jules tsai vous demandez
à demander bien alors une légende audrey
marnay qui fait rêver les adolescentes
toutes les jeunes filles raine jambes
qu'à une légende de dhr et marne et quoi
il est mort et après sa devenu une
légende une légende vivante
regardez dinosaures qui va symbole
dinosaures jeune harry bel bien alors
c'est une petite fille s'il sort d'une
petite fille me dit si je me trompe à
berchères saint germain près de chat une
toute petite fille avec un vieux solex
comment même pas tu souhaites son papa
est informaticien ce moment est
secrétaire et alors cette adolescente
cette petite fille se trouve un peu trop
mince
elle déteste ces taches de rousseur on
se demande bien pourquoi
en classe on l'appelle la girafe selon
le taf et je dis ça pour les gens qui
l'ont un peu oublié en classe selon lui
on l'appelait babar hockey et c'est bien
c'est même contre moi je trouve ça très
bon exemple parce que vous appelez la
girafe on s'est moqué de vous promener
maintenant vous êtes un symbole de
adapté et dresser le bilan
quel meilleur pied de nez pour faire à
tous ces gens qui aiment et qui
s'accusait marc prieur exactement quel
espoir pour toutes ces gerra qui vous
regarde
à 14 ans cette petite girafe veut
s'acheter un scooter et à l'époque tout
le monde par des mannequins évidemment
c'est la mode des mannequins et alors
son papa travaille à paris en face d'une
agence de même cas et alors elle tient
plus elle n'en peut plus qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait un jour armé de quelques
113 agences de même qu'à et d'un
photomaton
car le seul c'est vrai ça mais nous
sommes le seul le seul bouc que vous
aviez à l'épaule
mon photomaton j'en avais une photo qui
me restait pas ce que je vais faire ma
carte d'identité
voilà donc elle prend le tram tout seul
elle va à paris c'est magnifique comme
une histoire ils sont sûrs comme acteur
et comme ça et alors vous avez dans une
agence et ils vous regardent pas la
première agence
et là c'est le viol collectif face à
l'aca c'est la première à jour de la
première agence vous mesuriez pas 1
mètre 80 vous aviez à peine 15 ans il
vous regarde pas et la deuxième agence
vous engage aussitôt et l'agent viva
vous y est toujours
j'y suis toujours vous êtes d'une
fidélité exemplaire exactement donc le
14 octobre 1995 jour de votre
anniversaire vous faites votre premier
défilé
c'est magique vous avez vraiment un
destin vous rendre ce jour là vous
rendez compte quand même
non c'est un signe du ciel ce un signe
du ciel ça oui bon et je suis je suis
arrivé là-bas le défi l'état 8h30
jusqu'à arriver à midi puisqu'il faut la
préparation j'arrive c'était un hangar
désaffecté à peu près donc y avait juste
les vêtements et quelques personnes et
j'arrive y avait personne
donc c'est assez inquiétant le jour de
mon anniversaire et après donc ça a
commencé à se meubler verts dans les six
heures du soir les mannequins ont
commencé à arriver maintenant vous ne
saviez pas vous arriver très en avance
je savais pas mon premier défilé on
arrive
nous l'avons rencontré dans cette poule
est plus grande quoi une évangéliste sa
chaleur marleau cascades mcmenamy et
c'est assez impressionnant passé le
conte de fées vraiment et votre
ascension sera fulgurante
ça a démarré ses livres 13e ouais très
vite alors toujours la même agence on
l'a dit est ce que vous êtes toujours
avec le même alexandre ben oui toujours
non c'est vrai oui c'est vachement
fidèles alors exactement ça va faire
trois ans et demi la girafe est monogame
et folk on peut dire tout ce qu'on veut
de laurent baffie llodra mais les
animaux il connaît bien d'accord non non
ça c'est vrai non sérieusement les
mustélidés bah oui mais ses limites
c'est quoi les mystères des mammifères
carnassier c'est quoi par exemple donner
un exemple de mustela le plus grand
représentant les blaireaux que tu
connais bien tous beaucoup à cette table
et on peut dire que le petit c'est
peut-être l'hermine est ce que ce
alexandre serait le père de votre enfant
eh bien pas du tout faux girafes et
coureuses bien on va savoir un tout
petit peu plus sur vous bon tout ce que
je viens de dire la maintenance et dans
les livres d'histoire c'est la légende
voudrait marne et les adolescentes liste
en bande dessinée en cours préparatoire
mais cinquième cette année avec ce
programme de soirées slam dictionnaire
aussi dans le dictionnaire aussi bien
maintenant on va savoir un peu plus on
ne bouge pas par le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien vous n'êtes pas bougé des
gens formidables
dès lors on est sympa quand même et
l'autre le bassiste à qui je ressemble
mois castaldi et tu sais qu'ils
ressemblent pas quand tu fais ça non
balle au centre
moi la différence c'est que je te met
pas la main sur la zone pour pas que tu
parles
matthieu lamy ailleurs fait bien
attention audrey marnay on se concentre
où
[Musique]
vous êtes bouddhistes en plus qu'en
penser ah je vais beaucoup de mannequins
sont bouddhistes sa cause de quoi là
pour moi c'est plutôt une façon de
penser rapprocher de niveau de séverine
ferrer vous savez que séverine ferrer
laval élévation de la pensée séverine
ferrer rencontrer le dalaï lama
elle est venue nous le raconter ici mais
j'ai le talent a mis le dalaï lama est
déjà venu à chartres aussi un bon bien
sûr voir vos parents quand mes parents
il est venu à la maison a laissé sa i vé
ça passe dès les mois je pense qu'ils
sont plusieurs en fait
alors est ce que vous préférez draguer
vous faire draguer battre et ça c'est
intéressant parce quand je me fais
draguer cher muret d'accord impossible
c'est bon à savoir est-ce que préféré
larguer vous faire larguer largué j'ai
toujours quitter mais mes conquêtes
d'enfance on va dire puisque j'ai eu 20
ans jonathan puis alexandre regarde
moment maintenant et donc et je me suis
jamais fait larguer donc j'ai pas
toujours l'arrivée ouais vous préférez
caresser ou vous faire caresser
ça dépend des jours aujourd'hui par
exemple maintenant sûr j'aurais été sur
la voie y est arrivé c'était parquet
gentil je travaille pour toi alors bien
ça dépend des jours donc aujourd'hui
c'est un jour avec peut-être puisque mon
âme est à new york donc aujourd'hui
peut-être et ses préférés vous faire
embrasser ou embrasser
j'aime bien quand ça vient des deux
simultanément
c'est un désir simultanées oui vous
croyez au désir simultané les scoops
rien l'amour fusionnel
ou est ce que vous croyez qu'il faut pas
trop se marcher sur les pieds de materna
salle de bains sont pas trop ce marché
saint-pierre matin mais on peut
fusionner bien est-ce que vous avez
besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour ou de
faire l'amour pour aimer des mets pour
faire l'amour des mets pour faire
l'amour et vous prier de tomber
naucelle vous était pas sûr lire talent
est là je suis content de la cap
supporters brestois balles les deux
réunis pour marquer je ne l'ouvrent je
vous laisse seul avec mon essai chacun
sa merde
on se concentre or et marne et c'est
votre vrai nom marne et oui c'est en
plus devient donc y aller tout de suite
bien quoi parce que ça fait un peu
pseudo drone armé abou ouais c'est un
peu comme axelle red
si bien que ça le sourire par exemple on
dira un pseudo tellement c'est beau non
ils étaient plus longs au moyen-âge
c'était quoi marnais de vernon au en
plus à une particule mai salle est vendu
ils ont vendu quel est le lieu idéal
pour une étreinte à part le podium géré
la plage à la plage bon je le jour la
nuit est le jour le jour très terne à
écouter le lieu où vous êtes incapable
de faire qui va être content si nous
regarde où j'en allemand vous avez vingt
ans maintenant vous êtes ouais je suis
majeur maxime c'est ce que vous faites
ce que vous voulez mais chardy sont à
partir de 20 ans ils peuvent venir
je serais incapable de faire l'amour
backstage chemin des filets ah ouais
alors qu'havas qu'ils font oui vous
préférez alors l'attention c'est
compliqué un mec qui bosse bien mais qui
est infidèle ou un mec est fidèle mais
qui baisent mal qui baisent malin
fidèles moi je suis très pour la
fidélité
ah oui vous pourrez même si beaucoup
non mais ça peut s'apprendre à batna il
va prendre à new york non pensez quoi
vous est ce que je vais vous poser la
question même temps oui moi je réponds
comme jeanne moreau je cherche je
cherche une troisième vague
voilà une qui est fidèle et qui bossent
bien voilà mais audrey alors c'est
marrant si vous êtes la première à me
répondre ça sert vous vous en foutez qui
baisent mal vous vous dites je vais lui
apprendre
non mais c'est bien qu'elle réponde ça
parce que c'est pas la mode justement
cette partie du monde et de ses
convictions c'est bien là la ses
convictions c'est une douleur d'une
famille bien
imaginons parlons d'adultère c'est un
jeu de l'esprit bien entendu le jeu vous
voyez bien mais je vous demande de
quitter le professeur division 2 minutes
si madame marie peut aller chercher une
bière dans le frigo est ce que vous
préférez pas savoir pendant que ce qui
fait en ce moment il préfère pas le
savoir où vous dites tous ces couples on
se raconte tout si on dit ou jeunesse de
partir ouais ouais donc avec un regard à
l'exemple du buzz mal mais j'ai pas
voulu dire ça non c'est pas ça s'appelle
la délation d'accord comment elle lui
avait appris est ce que c'est bien
est-ce que vous avez des fantasmes
encore non réalisés oui pas mal
ah bon et vous comptez manger temps oui
il a 20 ans bien sûr j'en viens tous les
jours donc un fantasme tous les jours
faut pas gâcher tout ça
il a de la chance alexandre c'est pour
ça qu'ils se barrent merci andré
bien alors mon invité suivant est encore
plus rare à la télévision ces derniers
temps que pierre arditi
mais il a choisi tout le monde en parle
pour venir parler de son livre de son
premier livre voici jacques dutronc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jacques dutronc mesdames messieurs
comment ça va ça va la dernière fois
qu'on s'est vus c'était il ya dix ans
vous venez de sortir van gogh n'était
pas finie bergère qui s'y colle aux
folies bergères était déjà là cc infos
intox web intox absolument magique ça
alors c'est extraordinaire parce que la
sortie de cette émission de double jeu
on s'était dit mme alors dutronc il nous
fait que des aphorismes sur toutes ces
réponses sont des aphorismes et alors
effectivement quand je lis le bouquin y
en a pas mal qui était dans l'émission
qui sont dans les puits et à une reprise
de vos interviews j'en ai retrouvé
j'en ai retrouvé pas mal dans pensées
répliques que je montre à nos amis voilà
pensées répliques
on cherche midi éditeur zoom mon garçon
vous le faites pas jack de quoi ça c'est
possible
jacques dutronc était excusé
vous êtes choqués audrey dutronc ça le
bail des banques en exergue du livre de
jacques dutronc il ya une phrase qui
résume le livre je n'ai strictement rien
à dire mais je tiens à ce que ça se
sache
mais déprécie alors on a envie
évidemment quand on est ici comme moi ce
soir de lire tout le livre alors
évidemment ça va pas être possible
comprenez bien j'avais tout faire alors
je vais en citer quelques unes au fur et
à mesure mais bon alors y en a une que
j'ai noté qu'il me fait rigoler si je
suis toujours à l'heure à mes rendez
vous comme ça je peux partir plus vite
elle est là quand on vous demande vous
buvez pour noyer votre ennui vous
répondez non pour l'irrigué seulement
est alors votre grande phrase plus
grandes phrases la vie est une maladie
mortelle transmissibles sexuellement
il ya aussi un ya aussi le cancer guéri
du cigare j'ai arrêté de croire au père
noël le joue dans une galerie marchande
il m'a demandé un autographe voilà quoi
passer que des trucs comme ça
les cats et je suis très fidèle quand je
fais l'ouverture j'ai fait aussi la
fermeture que j'aime bien là on va
parler de votre vie jacques 1
mais ça va être un peu long parce que je
suis tout jeune non plus mais banon
allez on y va
oui
oui souvenez d'alain barrière s'en
souvenait de la barrière
bien sûr bien alors vous êtes né dans un
car de police en 1943 pratique mourir
c'était le couvre-feu en 43 et de
bombardements alliés vous êtes né dans
un car de police ce qui fait qu'elle est
arrivée j'ai été déclaré la mairie du
17e et après avec votre ami gainsbourg
quand vous étiez ramassé par des cars de
police
en fin de nuit c'était bien après
finalement ça vous changez pas beaucoup
puisque vous étiez né dans un car de
plus j'avais l'impression oui c'est
exact de redevenir favorite et c'était
serré le but
serge ne savait pas lui mais enfin le
but c'était ça je revenais dans
l'enfance ici on fait alors le père
était ingénieur des ponts et chaussées
mais ce dont un ingénieur des mines
oui c'est ça c'est là qu'on fait c'était
un faux pas ce qu'ils faisaient était
musicien amateur et c'est vrai il ya
déjà le sens de la fantaisie propre
dutronc amateurs et de ressourcement
il aimait beaucoup la musique il joue
incognito avec un faux nez et souvent
pour ça que la plupart des on appelait
ça des dactylos aller dans les mêmes
balles vers la bastille donc pour par
reconnaître leurs tauliers entre
guillemets ce que vous permet téléphoner
ou il se déguisait avec lui pas quoi
moussa
mais il jouait il jouait très mal les
uns les personnes sont été aperçu il a
joué pendant 50 il avait un truc comme
mousse qui fumait beaucoup il ya une
phrase dans le livre sur lui vous dites
ça doit faire soixante dix ans qu'ils
fument
quand il est béni et la planche pour
pouvoir fumer et ma mère l'appelle
remorqueur c'est génial quand même mais
c'est vrai il avait il avait une
habitude aussi votre père qui était
qu'il va aussi vous avez hérité beaucoup
de votre père il balance et d'épée
énorme atteindre été recrutés d'une il
était à côté d'une jolie femme balançait
un pas énorme et il disait ne vous
inquiétez pas je dirais que c'est
d'ailleurs un nom en france du jeune
dutronc bon l'école ça vous motive et
pas spécialement non vous aviez des
rhumatismes c'est vrai c'est mal aimés
et votre mère vous est démodé ce que
c'était sympa pour sa sage et la plus
belle collection du lycée condorcet
redmond excuses
elle disait c'était comme je voulais ria
deux jours mon fils a rechuté été dans
le coup votre mère mais c'était ça
plutôt les chute dans l'escalier en
avant d'un ascenseur si l'ombre ou
quitter l'école à ces jeunes et vous
entrez dans une école de dessin
industriel mais votre vraie vocation
c'était vétérinaire comme tous les
membres 20 m à part cycliste où vous
avez cherché à soigner sa difficile lui
le faire donc vous avez 200 souris non
on est à peu près la vie privée j'ai
changé puisque j'ai quarante quatre
chats maintenant et quand même partir en
valais on les mettait dans le train et
vous mettiez d'autres cologne sur les
souris mais ça c'est lorsque je pars
moment j'en achetais dos tous et allez
donc lé combat énorme entre familles de
souris donc fait qu'elles se sentent
tout j'ai parfumé l'autre colloque se
reconnaissaient à l'autre cologne tout
ça s'arrange et tranquillement sans
bagarre alors à l'époque je vous redis
j'ai beaucoup parce que j'ai pas grand
chose
j'ai découvert les italiens aussi nash
vous écoutiez les camelots sur les
grands boulevards arriver ça vous
plaisait ça avait le père la souris
parce qu'il faisait l'écho d'une à avec
génie qu'est ce qu'ils vendaient pas une
souris une fois de plus c'est l'armée
qui était tenu par l'espèce de deux
petits fils
il faisait peur ils ont été formidables
je les connais vous ah bah oui mais
c'est marrant parce que je découvre que
d'abord dutronc était au lycée condorcet
qui paraît très loin du lycée jacques
decour
même âge donc on mettrait même quartier
que je faisais aussi les grands
boulevards johnny très bien du père la
souris les moules excuses de la mer de
dutronc ressemble beaucoup aux excuses
de la mienne et vous alors vous avez en
commun aussi des mets beaucoup des chats
et des riches et de lord essayé de fumer
le cigare où se trouve ici c'est ce soir
voilà donc en fait votre vraie passion
jacques dutronc c'était la musique est
alors à la trinité au soir de la trinité
or là c'est extraordinaire ça aussi
c'est un peu comme votre histoire m'a
dit des choses comme ça imaginez que
dans ce square d'attribution par la
trinité il y avait jacques dutronc qui
traînait il y avait johnny hallyday qui
à l'époque s'appelait jean philippe smet
il y avait dit michel nowak
donc vous imaginez que dans ce petit
score de nous amener les mecs qui jouent
et qui était ado c'est des gens qui sont
devenus parmi les chanteurs les plus les
plus connus dans l'est dans les dix ans
suivant quoi rêver serge aussi avant et
les serge aussi est il allé à l'école
communale rue blanche aussi c'est
marrant ça quand même vous avez sous ses
airs et là c'était un hit talent c'est
rigolo ça alors vous faites un premier
groupe qui s'appelle les tritons
peut-être moi je le sais demandez moi
mais après si vous connaissez le taureau
les cyclones quand même et savez vous
étiez pas le taureau vos annonces je
vais être le guitariste de faire partie
d'un des cyclones mais j'ai joué avec
mitchell surtout longtemps
ouais mais au départ je jouais que
johnny en effet un et cerise de groupama
était commandes génial époque vous
seriez est-ce qu'on sentait qu'il avait
vraiment ce potentiel
ah oui ça se sentait bien sûr un jour
jacques dutronc un peu le dire je crois
parce que maintenant il ya prescription
une fiancée les odeurs d'iris finances
et à la dernière minute tout était prêt
à acheter tout était prêt c'est vrai il
va voir la famille
il leur dit bah nan je vais pas épouser
votre fille et les gens y croyaient que
c'est une plaisanterie berry va j'espère
que ils ont enfin compris j'espère
bamako elle attend encore nous attend là
mais j'ai un peu honte avec le fameux
ouais j'ai un peu honte maintenant mais
enfin si je les fais à ce moment là
c'est qu'il fallait que je le faire il
valait mieux oui bah oui sinon je serai
pas la seule
alors alors ils ont dit les beaux
parents quand il leur a dit ça il est
drôle pour marié nettoyer ce qui fait un
parfait c'était quand même à l'époque on
disait vous savez je fais de la musique
etc où ça où je chante je ne sais quoi
c'est où je faisais que j'essaye de
jouer la comédie je sais pas quoi mais
qu'est ce que vous faites à part ça
c'est elle était présent cette époque là
là mais ensuite jacques dutronc part en
allemagne comme johnny hallyday comme
elvis presley il était de bon ton à
l'époque de faire son service militaire
en allemagne
quand on voulait devenir une rock star
et au retour donc mitchell les pirates
et champions vous devenez directeur
artistique par l'assistant directeur
chez vogue
là vous commencez écrire des chansons
rêver et en 65 vous rencontrer jacques
lanzmann quelle époque avec talent chef
de lui collaboration extrêmement
fructueuse évidemment puisque vous avez
fait parmi les plus grandes chansons
françaises les plus classiques en tous
les cas
et puis comme vous trouvé personne pour
les chanter vous décidez de les chanter
vous quoi oui c'est pas venu tout de
suite ça non non j'ai chanté ça tout à
fait en touriste puis je me suis
retrouvé là la can devant des caméras
je me suis retrouvé la télévision j'ai
dit voilà autant continuer oui ça vous a
pris fin comme ça quoi réveiller en
sursaut
ouais c'est pour ça que vous avez jamais
eu l'air d'y croire en fait parce que
départ si vous êtes tombé alors vous
êtes victime un peu du syndrome ce que
j'appelle le syndrome julien clerc c'est
à dire c'est à dire que julien clerc il
a fait des mélodies formidable écrit des
mélodies extraordinaire on parle
toujours de ses paroliers
vous remarquerez on parle de maurice
vallet on parle de rodage i
on parle de dabadie maintenant on parle
de carla bruni bon on oublie simplement
que je viens clair toutes les chansons
qu'il a chanté c'est en général lui qui
la composaient dutronc c'est pareil on a
beaucoup parlé de lanzmann on a dit les
paroles forme ils avaient tous là la
façon d'interpréter avec cette distance
ce recul que vous aviez est en fait les
musiques c'est vous qui les avez fait
rêver nous fait un bon compositeur
bonbons sûrement compositeur de chansons
non mais c'est vrai il a une phrase sur
la modestie dans son livre qu'est ce
qu'il dit c'est l'art d'être loué deux
fois mais je te dis à quelqu'un vous
êtes charmant mais non mais messi
[Applaudissements]
allez
damas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
lima vigie
[Musique]
ça c'est un truc regarde audrey je suis
en train d'essayer de snober aux grecs
et par cactus
[Musique]
oui
pas
ap / la veille et par 15
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
je me dis je c'est casse tête
monsieur
g
[Musique]
on veut
je sais je sais
la partie 2
[Musique]
d
paris
[Musique]
m
contre alléger
là c'est le pire on
plus est
avec ses dents
tous
la scène
quand il savait
quand il c'était un petit jard santé
bonne mine
l'état
il est sympa et un tyran méfiez-vous
c'est un trio jacques dutronc
est-ce que honnêtement quand on dit ça
ce qui fait qu'elle est très vous dites
c'est plus moi aujourd'hui ou qu'est-ce
que c'est bien mais c'est bien celle des
classes
si vous êtes content ou ça vous fait
chier entendre ça bah non parce que
quand je les vois que ça va ah bon
d'accord non mais vous êtes tellement
voyez comment vous êtes quoi on a
toujours envie de vous faire plaisir de
vous voir sourire vellaye heureux audrey
marnay catherine barma me demandent de
vous demander si vous aimez les chansons
de jacques dutronc
n'en demandez le demandait elles ont un
peu bercé mon enfance que mon père est
un grand fan ah ouais c'est la grand
mère elle adorait ça sort bien ouais bah
oui non c'est vrai qu'à l'époque en plus
il ya un truc extraordinaire est devenu
l'idole des jeunes un moment avec un
personnage très décalé parce qu'ils
avaient tous les cheveux longs
évidemment et vous avez des cheveux
courts un petit costard un peu un peu
étriqué vous n'aviez pas d'opinion
politique à l'époque tous l'ont été pour
la paix au vietnam vous vous étiez vous
en foutiez de ça c'était pas par
provocation des autres c'est que grâce à
la chanson les playboys j'étais habillé
à l'oeil
j'avais des pompes de shekhar me levant
j'avais des réductions suivant partout
chez fauchon ce que le jeu the rational
trop c'était pas mal mais on peut dire
une chose c'est que vous êtes un peu
années 50 c'est à dire votre style
d'humour de façon d'être ça fait plus
penser aux années 50 que que non mais
c'est pas un reproche à dans les années
5o rêver non mais c'est pas un reproche
parce que regarder les canulars que vous
faisiez par exemple les canulars de
canulars c'était des canulars très
années 50 j'ai pas fait un canular qui
consistait à appliquer les pompes à lui
acheter les mêmes en plus petit
or le lendemain le mec ouvert la porte
ils connaissent et pour opel avait
quatre tailles demoiselle essayer de les
mettre
il pensait que ses pieds avaient gonflé
si à chaque fois il y avait toujours un
malin mais qu'à lui fait un pote du
représentant qui êtes c'est le chauffage
par le sol ça fait dégonfler les femmes
y avait tout ça c'était un sketch et y
en avait un autre aussi c'était de
mettre un étron énorme dans un papier le
journal on l'a fait cela mais je n'ai
jamais fais moi de mettre le feu au
papier journal zahi sortez de là bas il
donner un grand coup de pied évidemment
dans le parc national on irait flec et
l'état n'inspire tiré dessus alors un
jour j'ai demandé la plus grande joie de
votre carrière
mais vous m'avez dit pas ce que je
faisais déjà les mêmes questions que
tout le monde peut s'en apercevoir et
c'est ça que je n'ai pas changé et c'est
pourrez vous m'avez répondu c'est le
jour où j'ai eu un gala annulé à 8
heures je suis rentré dans un hôtel
pourri pour lire les pieds nickelés
voilà c'était la plus grande joie de sa
carrière et la plus grande déception
la plus grande déception vous avez
répondu c'était décidé de me masturber
avec les pieds nickelés sa cellule c'est
traître alors bon après vous avez eue
avec l'ange man bouge pas qu'il y eu des
problèmes j'en sais rien à ma façon vous
êtes moins vu vous et moi travailler
ensemble et vous êtes retrouvé
il ya quelques années grâce à moi parce
que j'avais organisé 40 ans de 45 tours
s'est elle est meilleure qu'avant de
ceinture des 40 dernières années
évidemment le gagnant ça a été les cinq
heures paris c'est absolument normal
parmi toutes les chansons de l'après
guerre justement est ce jour là bas vous
êtes retrouvé
j'ai pas beaucoup revu par la suite en
ferons - mais le plaisir de vous revoir
ensemble jacques lanzmann ou et il sait
jacques lanzmann la jacko jacko monsieur
landman je recherche une paire de
moustaches
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant je n'ai pas vu dans le micro
monsieur lansman si tout est en ouest
par contre on s'est entendus il ya un
jour ou deux mais je lui dis c'est
jacques dutronc et m'a dit lequel parce
que il m'a dit ça fait trois fois qu'on
m'appelle en dix ans et du tronc gp
presque à faire comme l'histoire la
fameuse histoire donnery commercial de
lui chanter au téléphone quelque chose
dans un magazine qui se vendent
librement vous avez déclaré il ya
quelques semaines jacques lanzmann que
vous seriez prêt aujourd'hui à faire un
faire un nouvel album pour et avec
jacques dutronc affirmant sûrement parce
que je pense qu'on a beaucoup de choses
à dire ensemble et que doit se dire mais
et je suis sûr qu'on peut faire quelque
chose de bien et ça ne sera pas très
très difficile parce que c'est pas la
peine de refaire ce qu'on l'a fait ce
qui est intéressant c'est de faire ce
qu'on a envie de faire maintenant
j'avais trop envie de chanter chaque a
tellement changé physique beaucoup plus
que ces peines d'amendés allant prendre
vous avez envie de chanter c'est même
pas une question de flemme sait il faut
faut en avoir envie pas faux bond mais
bon je peux pas faire deux milliards de
choses à la fois je veux dire bon il y
en a qui baise et qui fument en même
temps d'autres qui fument après c'est
tout les reins étaient là dessus
[Musique]
on applaudit jacques dutronc j'adore val
et jean-luc delarue s'était donc 40 ans
de 45 tours et chansons meilleur des
quarante ans il est cinq heures paris
s'éveille voilà bien alors 73
en fait toute votre ville ouais on est
en 73
on n'est pas rendu abbas est plus long
que la ville de dhr et marne et à vous
prenez prétexte de la naissance de votre
fils pour dire ben je vais m'occuper de
lui c'est une bonne excuse pour arrêter
la scène quoi en fait je n'ai fait ni
l'un ni l'autre
c'est plutôt enfin c'est plutôt françois
s qui s'est occupé de thomas oui au
cinéma au cinéma vous êtes génial tout
de suite
premier film sébastien et puis ensuite
pialat enfin il n'a eu d'autre mais je
cite pialat à van gogh parce que ça a
été quand même un événement vous dit en
parlant de pialat pour justement on en
revient ce concessionnaire pour le vexer
faut le flat et voilà et alors il ya un
truc très sympa dans ce film c'est qu'à
un moment vous il avait écrit vous êtes
avec mademoiselle gâcher la fille du
docteur gachet dans la voiture lors nang
et à un moment il y avait cinq pages de
texte et c'est pas que je n'ai pas voulu
les apprendre c'est que vous avez réduit
vous et transformer les cinq pages de
texte en un regard est exact c'est par
fini anti sûrement mais je crois pas
c'est par d'allant non mais c'est vrai
que j'étais pas très convaincu de ses
cinq pages que vous avez dit il faut
connaître le texte pour se permettre de
ne pas le dire je vais bien alors vous
êtes tourné aussi avec godard vous dites
c'est comme un psy mais c'est lui qui
paye là et puis alors le pire si
spielberg
alors ça c'est incroyable match si
j'avoue là je vous comprends pas un jour
steven spielberg demande à jacques dit
je voudrais pouvoir c'est ça c'était
pourquoi le faire libérer
c'était une diana jones oui je crois
qu'il voulait que vous soyez indiana
jones ne sais pas mais je parle très mal
l'anglais donc la spielberg rencontre
dutronc et lui dit j'aimerais que vous
jouiez
indiana jones je vous ai dit beaucoup de
conneries pendant le déjeuner quand même
non sûrement parce qu'il n'a jamais
rappelé qua non bonsoir jean marie
messier mesdames messieurs pour
l'applaudir bien et puis alors après bon
bah vous rencontrent alors françoise
hardy bon elle vient souvent ici on sait
à peu près comment ça se passe chez vous
donc j'ai pas vous poser beaucoup de
questions parce que c'est tout en
parlais tout à l'heure de l'amour
fusionnel audrey ce qu'il faut être
comme ça toujours collés l'un sur
l'autre et se marcher sur les pieds dans
la salle de bains ou est-ce qu'il faut
prendre un peu de distance pour
conserver du mystère du fantasia qu il a
résolu le problème une fois pour toutes
avec vive enfin un état chacun c'est ça
le ferait voilà et ça dure parce que
tous ces coupes du showbiz ils ont tous
divorcés sauf le vôtre c'est vrai
regardez johnny et sylvie et quand on
vous dit quand on vous dit ça fait 30
ans où vivait avec françoise hardy vous
dites on vous dit ça fait trente ans de
vie commune et vous répondez 30 ans de
vie peu commune
c'est joli mais c'est d'ailleurs mais
pas inventé c'est la 1e puis quand on
vous parle de moi je vais demander
d'ailleurs c'est moi qui lui ai demandé
quel don de la nature voudriez avoir
vous avez dit j'ai déjà le doigt vers le
pousse vers la queue verte et je suis
mariée qu'une belle plante alors il ya
un truc on ne peut pas être tout le
temps d'accord c'est i muvrini
vous savez qu'ici quand quelqu'un parle
trop quand quelqu'un parle trop il est
mosaïque est et on lui diffuse un petit
morceau dit m'ouvrit ni et vous c'est
vos potes ils me voulaient
oui l'effet que ça nous fait en
métropole c'est marrant et ses bien
aimés ouvriers vous a plutôt un mec qui
va le rendre à caen s'en servir c'est
bien moi je suis là encore ça cet été
malgré lui ouvrit ni 1g qu'un faux-nez
évidemment avec une fausse barbe et une
perruque mais les signes et gildas sur
les odeurs bon alors votre maison en
corse ça va peser toujours la base est
tranquille vos choix vos potes là oui
c'est vrai que vous parlez au chat oui
et vous fait quoi quand il voit
quelqu'un il parle au château quand
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive dans le
chemin il fait comme ça comme avec son
portable pour faire croire qu'ils
parlaient pas ce que je fais sûrement de
téléphoner voilà alors vous avez demandé
à l'époque comment vous avez fait pour
vous faire accepter par les corps si
vous avez répondu rien justement la
situation politique en corse vous y
intéressez un petit peu non non non vous
en foutez qua non je vend sous forme de
lyncher intéressé s'intéressait déjà pas
la politique il ya 30 ans et encore pas
du tout maintenant
oui oui vous avez choisi la corse par
paresse à nous c'est pour la beauté
toute façon vraiment et bien sûr une
belle phrase sur le travail vous dites
ça paye dans le futur le travailleur que
la paresse ça paye comptant
alors vous vivez là vous avez la
retraite de la sacem ne savais pas ça
vous verser une retraite la sacem bien
sûr je suis retraité jeté à la retraite
alors vous dites je suis ni riche ni
bien portants on vous croit malade
toujours non c'est vrai vous avez vous
le savez déjà au moins dix fois moins
combien de fois on m'a appelé en faisant
de ce que jacques dutronc est mort je
suis content de vous voir
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit il me faudra
mettre sur ma tombe encore et encore non
mais c'est vrai tous les journaux toutes
les télés ont votre micro prête
pourtant vous buvez plus la 6ème
d'algériens là je comprends pas
longtemps j'ai demandé tu veux quoi j'ai
demandé c'est parti vite je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai arrêté bavardons le jour
où j'ai arrêté de boire je vais te
bourrer ben voilà ben voilà mais non il
n'a pas arrêté de 6 et une analyse
d'urines ça jacques dutronc va faire
lentilles portrait chinois
vous connaissez le portrait chinois
voici le portrait chinois je vous dis si
fêter un site était une fleur si vous
étiez une fleur et vous me dites je
serai à mieux autisme je serai une
rosemont lente et portrait chinois c'est
autre chose on ne bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il existe une rupture a pas de livre
isme rupture d'anévrisme on voit pas
vrai c'est rapide
une injure janyk et le compte est mort
qui tâche il a souvent pris au mot dite
des 'quatre sir paul dumont est une
maladie incurable de toute façon dans la
griffe plus que jamais les gens à plein
un accident travail bien sûr c'est donc
une perversion par se parler de soi même
à la troisième personne a oui comme
alain delon de l'autisme de l'impérieuse
la prof lui il ya des plombiers aussi
que monsieur bah oui ils disent comme ça
comment il va et j'adore un vice par
l'alcool les femmes ça va ensemble non
une arme un pistolet ou un supplice je
ferai pas aux chinois mais le monopoly
[Rires]
moi j'aurais répondu la salle de gym
mais ça je suis dit ça tous les jours
maintenant c'est ça devient une routine
si vous étiez un dictateur je serai
metteur en scène ce métier une torture
la torture jean pierre foucault j'ai un
titre
on pense et puis qu on cherche midi
bien
alors avant de recevoir notre invité
suivant voici les résultats du jeu des
compagnons des stars dont gad elmaleh
donc vous en souvenez lundi c'était gros
poisson c'est laurent qu'il avait donnée
est la compagne de gad c'est anne
brochet alors on a joué la semaine
dernière la semaine d'avant
on a joué pour avec claire keim
connaissez claire keim une charmante de
personnes lundi c'était john un don il
ya des gens qui ont répondu david
douillet notamment stéphane parce que
jojo non c'est pas ça
il ya des gens que chris a répondu joe
dassin non c'est pas possible alors joe
joe joe le taxi
il y en a pas mal qui ont répondu samy
naceri notamment jean-michel et corinne
c'est pas samy naceri la bonne réponse a
été trouvé par karine emilie ludivine et
bosso et c'est frédéric diefenthal qui
est le compagnon de claire keim et qui
m'y ont autorisé le dire bien entendu
sinon je ne dirais pas à vous connaissez
la discrétion
bien sûr il m'a dit ce terreau est
légendaire évidemment rien alors ça va
être quoi l'enjeu cette semaine ya pas
de jeu c'est jean marie messier cette
semaine alors justement tout le monde en
parle c'est l'homme de l'année il est là
le voici
jean marie messier
jean marie messier bonsoir bienvenue
vous avez 44 ans on vous appelle au
départ j2m jean marie messier
après les guignols l'on surnommé j6m
jean marie messier moi même maître du
monde
d'où le nom de le titre de votre livre
j6m points comme chez hachette
littérature qui sait sous-titré faut-il
avoir peur de la nouvelle économie alors
sur la quatrième de couverture qui est
ici en général l'auteur leur lit ça il
est écrit que vous êtes l'un des maîtres
du monde vous l'avez relu ça ben oui
paris qu'on le dit voilà donc vous dites
vous que je puisse penser je me suis
lavé à denis maintenant moi je trouve ça
c'est rigolo d'abord vous n'êtes pas
patron si vous n'êtes pas un peu mégalo
ouais ce qui est un peu ce qui est un
peu fou c'est de faire ce qu'on essaye
de faire en ce moment par exemple
ralentir ou français d'en faire un
numéro un dans les métiers de la com
ouais c'est ça me rappelle un peu le le
slogan de 68
soyez réalistes demandez l'impossible
c'est le genre de défi que jamais les
formes essayé très fort
maître du monde mais il arrive à nous
parler de 60 x et bien alors c'est vrai
ils ceux ci étant que la fusion en
vivendi universal faites vous un homme
très puissant vous êtes deuxième groupe
derrière aol time warner
je vais dire tout ce qu'il ya dans ce
groupe et là évidemment tout le monde va
être soit sentir un peu con alors dans
le téléphone va vous avez laissé faire
un dix millions d'abonnés à la pas
partout pendant sa passe pas partout
moi je je prends les réclamations je
cherchais mon portable emmerder avec sa
bien alors donc le téléphone sfr 10
millions d'abonnés à la télé canal + 7
millions d'abonnés dans 10 pays sur
internet vis-à-vis et aol france vous
allez le vendre aol france en musique
alors vous avez universal music est
numéro un dans le monde
en cinéma universal les studios
universal la production de thin film
universo 14000 film deuxième librairie
mondial de films en édition le groupe
havas c'est à dire la moitié d'édition
française avec la rousse plomb l'express
l'expansion
alors ça évidemment tout de suite c'est
impossible
j'ai édité chez hachette
[Musique]
ah oui mais c'est normal attendait non
non non
[Musique]
merci et oui on a droit à un triomphe
romain au moins ça montre que vous avez
vu gladiator voilà oui c'est chez vous
aussi le grinch le grinch et chez vous
ou dans les clubs
la momie c'est chez vous ouais ouais
c'est énorme
alors vous êtes devant murdoch devant
bertelsmann devant disney devant sony
devant de la rue votre groupe est même
plus gros que le groupe de jean luc
delarue votre livre c'est une mare du
mal vous avez eu du mal mais vous y est
arrivé c'est bien votre livre aussi à
beaucoup de succès ainsi je suis pas
vous êtes à combien soixante dix mille
exemplaires
soixante mille à peu près rice et bien
il paraît que vous regardez tous les
jours les vendre c'est vrai je
regarderai ce matin si vous faites un
bouquin c'est pour qu'ils se rendent
non c'est normal alors vous savez qu'à
une tradition dans cette émission
maintenant on va parler d'eux on va
parler de votre livre c'est ça hein
je signale arnaud de montebourg arnaud
montebourg que même les maîtres du monde
le font donc la prochaine foire nos
efforts à la chorale faire voilà parce
que quand même là on a vu qu'un maître
du monde le fait donc vous avez deux
idées géniales pour ce bouquin la
première c'est le titre j6m points comme
c'est évidemment de reprendre
l'expression des guignols très bonne
idée
et puis vous dévoilez votre salaire
alors ça évidemment c'est tellement rare
en france des patrons qui les voilà vous
gagnez combien l'an dernier j'ai gagné
20 millions de francs bruts c'est-à-dire
7 millions de francs mais ouais mais
c'est quand même un crêpe tous que tout
ce qu'on fait prendre
vous en pensez quoi vous là où je peux
je peux avoir des problèmes éventuels
c'est quand michelin annonce qui font
des bénéfices absolument gigantesque pas
que parallèlement leur directeur de la
com annoncent qu'ils vont virer 3000 mec
ça c'est inécoutable d'ailleurs ils
savent très bien que c'est écoutable
s'est fait un scandale
la raison ils ont des pierres peut
l'être ils ont bien fait puisqu'il avait
mieux à faire
oui alors audrée vous ce qui vous choque
en fait c'est pas tellement que jean
marie messier gagne 20 millions par an
c'est qu'il lui reste que 7 millions
voilà c'est votre côté américain c'est
peut-être n'aurais-je pas je pense que
tu menaces et choqué de ce qu'ont fait
prélever mais c'est ça qui vous choque
c'est les 13 millions qui donne l etat
et les 13 millions ça sert à faire des
hôpitaux à faire des crèches à faire des
roues alors il n'ya pas concernés est ce
que je peux te recommander ce livre zoom
zoom mon garçon et 13 millions jean
marie messier n'ont pas atterri à
l'hôpital nicole de l'épinette une
cancérologue qui s'occupe d'enfants
il ya plus que neuf lits dans son
service et des enfants qui meurent ils
les enfants qui ont le cancer ont dit
aux parents
votre enfant en import trois semaines et
elle se bat et des ailes technique des
gosses pour ça et avec sa propre volonté
et ses systèmes d et je peux te dire que
les 13 millions de messier ils vont pas
beaucoup à l'hosto
la politique quand on vote aux élections
c'est qu'on voit les gens qu'on lycées
pour dépenser l'argent qu'on leur donne
donc il faut bien les choisir
ça vous choque vous ça vous choque pas
vous en foutez qu'on gagne 20 millions
par an c'est à dire que je félicite
monsieur de gagner ça mais pourquoi pas
tout le monde devrait gagner ça mais le
problème c'est qu'il voudrait beaucoup
plus encore on n'en finit plus attendez
j'ai vu claudia schiffer qui est
pratiquement retraite si j'ai bien
compris et gagnent beaucoup plus que ça
ouais en retraite non mais c'est vrai
quand on part exactement à l'ego l'est
aussi c'est parler de ça je peux pas
coco et c'est vrai quand on vous parle
de ça ou parler d'anelka qui viennent
aussi beaucoup d'argent effectivement
voilà il ya quand même une limite pour
un patron ouais c'est moi je peux avoir
de parachutes dorés lire je gagne très
bien ma vie j'assume je trouve que je le
mérite mais par contre l'idée de toucher
un pactole encore si je dois partir un
jour sa chance à un supporter comme si
vous partez vous êtes avait gelé dit je
me suis engagé jean marais sera pas
j'aurais pas le chèque appelez moi si
vous êtes viré de vie vendée
j'aurai toujours un bol de soupe pour
vous trouver un truc alors le bilan
attendait quel bilan vous fait de vous
ai fait beaucoup de promo pour votre
bouquin vous avez fait des télés des
radios des journaux quel bilan vous
faites de ça ce que je trouve sympa
c'est quand vous allez dans un endroit
comme en arrivant là sur le plateau puis
quelqu'un qui vient avec le bouquin qui
vous dit vous pourrez mettre une petite
dédicace
ouais
avant de passer un peu plus sérieusement
au contenu du livre moi j'ai juste une
question à poser sur le look
pourquoi avant cette campagne de
promotion vous êtes un homme organisé
vous préparez bien les trucs vous êtes
tenace pourquoi vous n'êtes pas fait
beaucoup vous coiffer comme moi en gros
dire pourquoi avoir la raie sur le côté
tout ça pourquoi pas avoir une coiffure
un peu plus moderne préféreriez en
brosse non non je sais pas je vous pose
la question que j'avais pensé à ça non
parce que vous faites un peu enfant sage
quoi ouais un peu trop c'est mon côté
votre grande idée vous avez une grande
idée quand même et c'est ce qui fut fait
évidemment votre force et le parler vrai
c'est à dire que finalement à la
différence des hommes politiques et de
certains animateurs de télévision vous
vous imposez un devoir de transparence
et vous dit les choses quand on vous
pose des questions jalousie répondait je
crois qu'un patron aujourd'hui avec nos
entreprises qui grossissent qui ont plus
en plus d'influencé sur sur la vie et
sur la vie de chacun
on a un devoir qui est de s'expliquer
aux mains de voir qui est qui est celui
de la transparence et s'expliquer par
seulement vis-à-vis de ses actionnaires
de s'expliquer vis-à-vis des
consommateurs visitent ses clients et
vis-à-vis des citoyens
quand vous voyez des choses comme le
comportement de certaines grandes
entreprises pétrole et allemande une
marée noire
sa peau avait démarré oui et je crois
que aujourd'hui ou avec internet
n'importe quelle information disponible
partout tout de suite il y a un devoir
de transparence et un patron doit
accepter de s'expliquer et pourquoi est
ce qu'un patron ça devrait forcément
être un [ __ ] un tueur en costume
cravate et c'est ouais pas plus de
raison qu'un patron ce uniquement ça que
de se dire parce qu'on est sur un
service public faut faire des émissions
qui n'ont alors là vous êtes vous êtes
un grand patron
mais en même temps pas très grand pas
très grand d'ailleurs assez rapide bravo
il sait comment passer aux aveux
non mais vous avez un côté social alors
qu'il vient sans doute de votre
éducation catholique parce qu un
catholicisme social tout le monde
connaît il ya des entreprises qui sont
obligés pour des raisons de compétition
de faire des licenciements comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure
moi j'ai la chance d'être à la tête d'un
groupe qui créent des emplois je trouve
ça plutôt bien
de la même manière que quand on voit la
richesse créée par des entreprises que
les salariés en aient leur tour au
travers de l'epargne salariale
je trouve ça normal c'est un geste de
défi envers les actionnaires
oui le fait que non salariés c'est quand
même eux qui bossent tous les jours pour
la richesse des actionnaires c'est
normal qu'ils ont récupéré une partie
d'elle
et
marie messier à la manque et pas
n'importe qui à la main qu il dit en
parlant de votre plan d'epargne groupe
il dit que c'est une aumône paternaliste
ouais mais ça moi je fais je trouve ça
je trouve ça choquant je trouve que
c'est du c'est du mépris parce que quand
un salarié part en retraite qu'au
travers du plan d'epargne groupe il peut
s'acheter une maison un appartement
c'est pas de la démagogie c'est pas de
l'amour etc à la main qu'ils aillent
demander à mes salariés s'y trouve que
c'est de le monde de pouvoir participer
comme ça la richesse que crée
l'entreprise faut pas faire de démagogie
mais pas dans l'impasse entre dans le
sens des choses qu'on peut qu'on peut se
demander mais c'est la question que je
veux moi que j'avais envie de vous vous
posez c'est que vous êtes un patron
visiblement très puissant aujourd'hui
mais je me demande si cette puissance
n'est pas relative à la force énorme qui
représentent les actionnaires et quel
est votre quelle est votre marge de
manoeuvre par rapport à vos bonnes
intentions par rapport aux intentions
des gestionnaires qui peut être
quelquefois sont moins pur que les
vôtres et si l'actionnaire dit bon ça
n'est plus rentable et l'on dégage ça
c'est votre pouvoir
soyons clairs les actionnaires ils
peuvent me gérer mais j'aimerais
peut-être jusqu'à noël bien alors je
m'en vais mais si on peut dire aussi
vous êtes resté très simple par exemple
vous faites du rtt ce que la
récupération du temps de travail c'est à
dire qu'une fois par semaine le mercredi
et l'artothèque la retraite et vous
allez voir vos enfants le mercredi
alors chez vous je sais pas si c'est
vrai nous le dira mais il n'y a pas de
tableau il n'y a pas de meubles anciens
afin vous dites je suis pas de jets de
cette non c'est pas mon truc
vous n'avez pas une limousine avec les
vitres fumées et des assistants qui vous
a vu neveu cigarettes par exemple non
alors j'en mets mais si vous n'avez pas
non plus beaucoup d'épousés les cas
d'une le lépine non avec le pognon vous
avez pour y avoir plusieurs
bah vous avez vécu voilà c'est la même
depuis 20 ans en plus et à l'épreuve de
physique dans un lycée donc vraiment ces
voiliers bon c'est pas vous êtes simple
finalement c'est la fille d'un général
quoi donc pour élever les enfants c'est
pas idiot s'est rencontré en faisant du
ski
ouais mais qu'est ce qu'elle dira quand
vous irez dîner avec julia roberts et
hollywood j'espère bien qu'elle me
laissera dîner inclus en mer c'est là
vous allez voir le début des emmerdes
jean-marie j'essaie de vous critiquer
mais j'avoue c'est compliqué dans le
prologue de votre livre en plus vous
vous critiquez vous même si vous êtes
très malin vous dites dans le prologue
du vif jean marie tu en fais trop
donc comme ça après c'est difficile de
vous dire jean marie tu en fais trop
puisque vous l'avez dit dans le prologue
du livre ouais ça c'est ce que j'entends
tous les jours est vous êtes d'une
habileté audousset
alors bon vous en faites trop dans les
médias
moi je trouve pas vous vendez votre
livre comme tout écrivain je n'y a pas
plus que frédéric beigbeder en tous les
cas vous êtes vous est visé par cette
notoriété un peu soudaine quand on en
fait beaucoup dans les médias
il faut être clair vous en prenez aussi
en retour plein infinie oui mais il ya
les deux aspects c'est vrai vous avez un
photographe en permanence avec vous qui
vous photographier tout le temps alors
ça c'est le genre de truc c'est la
rumeur 52 11 ans s'est dit une fois et
après pendant des années ouais les gens
le répète c'est pas vrai je n'ai pas de
photo mais très bien c'est pas comme
drake et à chaque fois qu'elle fait
quelque chose c'est toujours et j'espère
bien que draps
plusieurs photos audrey elle pose pas
nous ont même fermé non plus d'abord
comme maire qu'est ce que tu m'as dit
catherine beaucoup de colloques beaucoup
de séminaires vous porter la bonne
parole vous appelle jean marie mais si
vous savez quand même vous aimez bien
quand même expliquer vos actions vous
j'adore ça adhère il ya une toute petite
histoire sur la fusion convient de faire
ouais c'est le jour où pour expliquer ce
que c'est qu'une fusion mme c'est pas
toujours très simple c'est le jour où
j'arrive paradis c'est écrit par saint
pierre qui me dit quand même vous êtes
un type bien et fait pas mal de choses
et droit au paradis etc
il y à côté de moi saint thierry qui va
vous accompagner dans votre appart
qu'europe 1 tiret me prend par le bras
nous l'apport de l'apa et là je découvre
plein de diable des flammes des gens
torturés
j'écoutais ça tire et quand même
c'est plutôt un mec bien j'ai essayé de
faire des choses j'ai droit au paradis
mais vous a pas dit on vient juste de
fusionner avec claudia plaisir
il fait plaisir c'est de voir que
finalement vous choisissez saint-thierry
et pas saint pierre c'est frais ça fera
plaisir à pierre lescure en tout cas moi
je suis très flatté bien alors non ronde
il a pété les plombs messier moi je
crois pas mais comment est ce que vous
voulez comment est ce que vous voulez en
apporter la preuve maintenant bon votre
image de l'église saint-jean mag vous
n'êtes pas arriver là quand même sympa
vous connaissez des affaires quand même
le business temps en temps il faut comme
ça non ouais et plutôt proprement
évident tous les jours que vous vous
c'est pas vous qui avait du sang sur les
mains
donc ça c'est pareil quand il faut
soyons clair quand il faut virer un
collaborateur je le fais je le dis en
face pourquoi d'accord et effectivement
il faut pas il faut pas dire n'importe
quoi quand vous êtes un patron vous
devez prendre des décisions difficiles
vous devez virer des gens de temps en
temps c'est pas le truc le plus agréable
mais on fait pas que créer des emplois
ont fait pas que mais quand vous était
arrivé mais je perds les arrivées la
génération zoo en guy dejouany vous a
choisis pour le poly succéder il y avait
un certain nombre de barons qui était là
depuis des décennies c'est évident il a
bien fallu les mais ils ont essayé de me
d'abord
c'est bon c'est pour jacques dutronc
parce que c'est vrai qu'à la barrière on
n'a plus tellement l'occasion de
l'entendre non merci
alors messieurs vous savez d'où ça vient
messier me si ben presque c'est un petit
sentier surélevé dans le bocage normand
pour aller à la messe
en évitant de marcher dans la boue c'est
quelqu'un sans recours que tu viens de
raconter tout ça vu que j'ai raconté que
j'ai résumé là alors vous venez d'un
milieu de petite bourgeoisie catholique
votre père était expert comptable vous
étiez petits chanteurs à la croix de
bois quand vous étiez petit je vais vite
à polytechnique l'ena et alors là il
avertit on parlait de total tout à
l'heure au moment où jean marie messier
s'apprête à faire l'ena il écrit à total
en leur disant je voudrais faire un mba
ward est ce que vous pouvez me financer
le fbi et puis après je rentre chez vous
c'est comme ça que ça se passe j'imagine
pour les gens qui font des études est
donc total lui répond enfin le mec en
question chez total lui répond votre
écriture témoigne d'un manque évident
d'ambition ça ne veut rien dire en fait
pas répondre par un pompiste aussi peut
pas savoir à ils sont meilleurs pour
mazout et les mouettes
après moi je les lui tord la vie soyez
la place de démarrer aujourd'hui alors
ou inspection des finances
et là vous devenez conseiller de edouard
balladur alors ministre des finances
avait là ça se corse arditi va vous
trouver moins sympa pourquoi les
balladuriens racontez-moi à ce point-là
l'opposé d'une révélation du tout ouais
c'était le grand amour avec lui non
enfin tu parles dans tout bien tout
honneur bien sûr écouté j'ai passé j'ai
passé deux ans avec lui qui était de
zone est superbe c'est insuffisant pour
compenser pas suffisant pour qu'on vous
colle une étiquette mais par contre
suffisant pour dire que oui il m'a donné
il m'a rendu un sacré service
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
apprécient dans leur vie de trouver deux
trois hommes ou femmes qui à un moment
donné on avait bien sûr mais c'est vrai
qu'elle est bon vous vous êtes un petit
peu aujourd'hui l'homme qui parle vrai
j'étais à leur devoir de transparence
edward c'est pas le cas quoi je veux
dire il ya quand même un langage très
faut traduire quoi tout dans un loader
pour edward et tous nos hommes
politiques quand vous regardez ce qui se
passe sur sur les affaires sur la
corruption
tout le monde sait que ça existait en
france tout le monde sait que c'était le
cas pendant pendant des années ça sert à
quoi de faire semblant de rien voir
ouais il vaut mieux s'en expliquer une
bonne fois pour toutes alors après la
compagnie générale des eaux guiche
dejouany vous demande de venir lui
succéder alors l'époque c'est la
tourmente judiciaire évidemment parce
que compagnie générale des eaux et cela
m'avait filer du pognon aux partis
politiques at the rose et 26 cas de le
dire oui et donc votre grande idée une
grande idée c'est d'appeler ça vivant
dit parce que maintenant à la télé quand
ya un procès c'est la cge et quand il ya
un succès c'est vivant 10 c'est très
malin mais cge ça voulait dire quoi
compagnie gérard réseau voilà et je me
suis retrouvé un jour en chine devant un
ministre chinois wen qui me voyant il
savait vaguement qui avait une société
d'eau en france il me trouvait beaucoup
trop jeune pour être président de cette
société
donc il m'a pris pendant un quart
d'heure pour le fils de jérôme monod à
l'époque le patron de la lyonnaise des
eaux réseau et je me suis brûlé si tu
veux développer ton groupe un tout petit
peu hors de france
c'est un terrain changer de nom se met
sérieusement là est ce que vous croyez
pas que vous dépenser beaucoup d'argent
en publicité
c'est à dire que votre groupe achète
beaucoup d espace dans l'express en
nouvel obs dans le point dans les
quotidiens la télé et dans les radios
est-ce que s'il disait le procès vivant
dit au lieu de dire le procès de l'ex
cge est ce qu'ils auraient moins de pub
nom le dit là non soyons clairs il n'y a
rien de plus con qu'un groupe qui a un
problème avec un journal et qui dit je
vais les punir en leur sueur cran la pub
libre est d'ailleurs en général
aujourd'hui il suffit que le journal 10
on a dit du mal de vivendi nous on sucre
et la publicité c'est encore plus
dévastateurs alors c'est vrai que la
compagnie générale des eaux
ils vendent de l'eau évidemment c'est
une rente de situation parce que j'ai
lancé des concessions qui sont accordés
pour des dizaines d'années alors en
échange je sais pas quoi mais enfin il
les mairies les municipalités ont
accordé des voiles à des concessions ce
qu'on appelle l'impôt robinet c'est à
dire qu'en fait on paye pour avoir de
l'eau bon alors est ce que vous vous
êtes arrivé vous dites est ce que je
passe une idée mais vous dites c'est
quand même pas drôle de vendre de l'eau
donc j'ai fusionner avec universal pour
marc et je préfère faire des films à
hollywood temps dessin sacrément beau
métier devant de l'eau c'est moi un look
de dîner avec julia roberts quand même
fait gerber c'est un bon moment
malheureusement j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui en rêvent aussi
donc je suis pas sûr d'avoir mes chances
et patron du grossiste que je m'assure
enfin passons je serais quand même je
vous le concède mais non sérieusement de
faire du cinoche que dans l'eau non pour
revenir à l'eau il y a quand même il ya
une vraie question vous avez aujourd'hui
plusieurs milliards d'habitants sur
cette planète qui n'ont pas accès à
l'eau j'ai chaque année des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants d'adultes d'ailleurs
un qui meurt deux prennent de pollution
de l'eau je trouve que c'est un c'est un
métier qui est sacrément qui est
sacrément noble alors la fusion allait
boucler sur le plan juridique c'est fait
nos avocats
vous êtes sûrs qu'ils ont bien tout
boucler avant ce crâne quand ils vous
avez lancé villa vive investi beaucoup
d'argent vis-à-vis c'est votre portail
internet coûte blais il ya un sans
papiers qui était assis là qui lui
l'avait déposé vis-à-vis aussi vous êtes
obligés de
ayez pas mal votre service juridique
on a négocié avec pas de vous un il se
plaint pas de vous je sais pas ce que
vous avez donné mais non mais on est
transparent à barack obama qui s'appelle
oui on a payé cette cette marque 25
millions de francs avant de lancer
vis-à-vis qui va vous coûter beaucoup
d'argent toute évidence votre service
juridique ils n'ont pas fait il ya une
pays 36 15 pour voir avec cette marque
existent et vont trouver que cette
marque était une marque super bon
d'accord valait mieux garder une belle
marque est rachetée plutôt que la corde
mais plutôt que changer de marque j6m
point comme celles entre il le dit avant
c'est à vous êtes bien j'avais redresser
on s'est aperçu qu'ils avaient un
brésilien qui vend des jouets sur
internet et dont le site s'appelle j6m
points comme on va parler des problèmes
maintenant et il y en a et y en a alors
je vais vous les citer il y en a
beaucoup que vous connaissez bon fédérer
tous ah bon évidemment c'est dur quand
on fait une fusion federer dont vous
appelle napoléon de votre surnom
napoléon voulu ressembler un petit peu
le problème que j'ai avec ça c'est que
c'est une histoire qui a plié de
commencer mais qui a bien fini et voulu
ressembler un peu j'aime pas trop quoi
ressemblait à pierre mondy dans un des
napoléons ne trouvez pas pierre vous
trouvez pas me lapp a connu pire
mondiale afin intense vous connaissez
jamiroquai
voilà c'est là qu'on tarde et le fait
bien
alors on arrive à canal et là
effectivement quand je parle de problème
alors évidemment lors de la fusion le 9
juin
lescure vous appelle et vous lui
annoncer la fusion et vous dit jean
marie est ce que je peux tu embrasses et
d'ille et pierre lescure et vous vous
lui répondez oui pourquoi pas j'en fais
autant
jusque là tout allait bien regarde moi
ces deux tares l'aude et depuis bien
escure mais c'est normal il se demande
s'il faut perdre son âme pour assouvir
son rêve et malgré vos dénégations
répétées est-ce qu'il est encore l'homme
de la situation
d'abord où il est l'homme de la
situation oui style c'est pas c'est pas
commun pour canal ouais canal il ya 14
ans personne n'y croyait
c'est devenu une société qui est la
première en europe en matière de
télévision payante et aujourd'hui c'est
une chance de devenir une société
mondiale c'est pas facile car les gens
qui râlent chez canal c'est évident
ouais mais pierre et le est sans aucun
doute le meilleur patron pour pour canal
la meilleure preuve c'est encore comme
toujours c'est les guignols qui leur
apportera par les négociales il ya
quelques semaines ils nous ont montré ce
n'était pas simplement le bisou par
téléphone c'était c'était beaucoup plus
chaud que ça entre pia les guinéens
alors parlons-en je voulais en parler
les guignols c'est eux qu'on trouvait le
titre j6m vous est ce qu'ils disent
quand même il dit ça c'est comme ça
c'est ce qu'on fait la télé mais entre
nous on appelle gros cul bah ouais non
mais bon oui ce que je veux dire
vous aimez vous les uns mènerait pas à
être gentil les guignols il s'agit pas
de les amener à être être gentil le
principal c'est qu'il soit drôle et
fascination sera toujours d'un bon
maintenant il faut vous éteignez la
lumière chez vous et ici aussi
jean marie messier questions simples
quoi que vous disiez est ce que vous
pensez sérieusement qu alain de greef
est encore l'homme de la situation en
tant que directeur des programmes de
canal plus ce que je crois c'est que
alain de greef et un homme de programme
remarquable par seulement derrière pour
les programmes de canal+ mais pour
l'ensemble des chaînes thématiques et
des différentes offres de canal et c'est
notre ambition pour lui le c'est pas mon
ambition pour lui c'est le choix qu'il
doit faire et un truc qui va c'est que
on entend beaucoup de critiques sur npa
en disant mais c'est dépassé ça a changé
et c'est qu'il faut d'abord moi je suis
pas nostalgique
gildas de caunes c'était génial du jeu
on s'est pas mal du tout et il ya un
truc qui est simple canal ça toujours
été à la pointe de l'innovation
on le doit de greffe et de greffe encore
énormément de choses à portet canal pas
de doute là dessus
[Applaudissements]
isabelle la question qui tue évidemment
elle alors bon tout le monde se lamente
beaucoup sur le sort de canal+ c'est
tout le monde se dit oh là là donc
journal le monde dans tous les journaux
est ce que pierre lescure va perdre son
travail est ce que l'un d'eux grave à
perdre son travail
est ce que vous croyez pas vous
finalement que canal a perdu déjà son
âme que finalement ce plan financier il
ya un gros déficit chronique qu'il ya un
dérapage du coût de grille que tu es les
pions en italie ce n'est pas la
meilleure affaire du siècle etc npa
franchement plus personne ne regarde
donc est ce que vous croyez pas que
c'est finalement seul de la montée sur
canal c'est pas là aussi un combat
d'arrière garde
il ya un truc qui restera si vous avez
97 ou 98 % des abonnés de canal qui à la
fin de l'année décide de se réabonner il
ça ça veut dire les jours le foot pour
les fils pour le foot
et puis pour quelque chose car en clair
quand même et quand même l'esprit canal
et on connaît bien dans cette émission
qui est une vraie forme d'impertinence
donc dernier problème les usa bon les
américains quand ils voient arriver des
français ils se marrent quoi ils disent
ça y est c'est des gogos qu'on va plus
mais le los angeles times est appelée
l'innocent canal+ a perdu beaucoup
d'argent avec carole co et quelques
temps on se souvient tous de l'aventuré
la mgm avec le crédit lyonnais puis tout
le monde enfin tous les gens qui ont
acheté des majeurs ont perdu leur
culotte
est-ce que vous avez pas peur ces
exemples la mgm s'étaient dirigés ou
c'est par un italien est voilà un peu
particulier et le crédit lyonnais était
destinée est le dindon de la farce
il était là pour apporter de l'argent il
n'avait absolument aucun contrôle sur ce
qui se passe
le moi je suis convaincu que
l'expérience de canal dans le cinéma
elle est utile pour contrôler universal
studios universal sony ce qui s'est
passé avec elle il ya quand même il ya
quand même une très bonne équipe quand
vous regardez les films qu'ils ont sorti
à la molina plagnard kovic la diète mx2
parce que le sait que c'est quand même
un truc extraordinaire bien comment va
l'action en bourse ça va ouais elle
depuis que la fusion est faite la sarre
mon charmant vous êtes content très bien
vous savez jean marie messier qu'on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
alors vous partez sur une île déserte
vous préférez une fille très laide ou un
mec très beau je préfère une fille puis
même ladd a way ah oui d'accord c'est un
vrai terreau jean marie messier est un
vrai terreau mail à mes salutations
circonstances atténuantes vous donner le
plus de circonstance est innovante un
vieux qui se tape des petites ou à un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles un
vieux qui se trame du petit vous
préparer pour au niveau de la norme et
l'autre bien alors un ami arrive chez
vous à l'improviste en pleine nuit
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus ce
qu'ils trouvent sur votre table de nuit
c'est que j'ai fait à balladur c'est là
imaginer et loire un ami arrive à
l'improviste chez vous sur la table de
nuit
qu'est ce qui vous choque le plus bête
le plus qui trouve mein kampf ou un
godemiché mein kampf mannequin et quoi
balladur mein kampf aussi mais c'est ce
que c'est qu'un god bien sûr qu'il ces
voitures qu'ils auront tous
alors ok puis à me lâcher un petit c'est
lamentable bien alors est-ce que vous
échangeriez une paralysie générale si
vous êtes tétraplégique pour le restant
de vos jours contre la faim de la famine
au bangladesh le chichi par net
je dis oui si je suis honnête on sait
bien que non est ce que vous êtes un
ambitieux qui a ramé ou un opportuniste
qui a eu de la chance j'ai un ambitieux
qaîda chance à battre alors on est
sérieux on part en vacances tous les
deux dans la montagne
il fait très froid il ya beaucoup de
neige à trois mètres de neige on peut
pas aller faire les courses je meurs
vous n'avez plus rien à manger vous me
manger vous commencez par quoi partie
bien doser le gros cube dakar dans
lequel jean-marie messier veut bouffer
le cueilleur d'essaim des périphrases
quiz par louise aussi je vous le dis on
été vu dans des collèges de khurais
qu'est ce que tu veux c 501 et ça se
sent toujours dernière question jean
marie messier vous laver les cheveux
tous les combien toujours tous les deux
jours où jean marie messier
6ème points comme chez hachette
littérature y est chez hachette on sait
bien
[Musique]
il a une qui va faire du cinéma à
hollywood dans pas longtemps un un
premier rôle aux draps le pata j'espère
bien alors le maître du monde de la
semaine dont j'aimerais évidemment vous
êtes un des maîtres du monde on l'a
assez dit qui pour vous le maître du
monde de la semaine à part c'est
peut-être jean marie messier d'ailleurs
mais le maître du monde cette semaine ça
était qui c'est le type qui est au samu
social que j'ai vu tout à fait par
hasard en trouvant sur envoyé spécial il
ya deux jours qui essayent de convaincre
un sdf qui est dans une cabine
téléphonique de venir prendre une
boisson chaude et dormir et de le
ramener le lendemain sa cabine
téléphonique qui visiblement est sa
maison il est arabe
je me souviens pas de ce moment mais
aussi à son prénom il s'appelle mohamed
et la manière dont il essaie de
convaincre cet homme qui était à la
dérive est absolument tout ce qu'on rêve
de voir chez les hommes aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qui est un langage d'amour
est d'une simplicité dans la discussion
qui est admirable qui force l'admiration
on ne comprend pas comment on peut être
anti arabes on se dit que peut-être être
chrétien c'est quelque chose comme ça
non sans l'ombre d'une hésitation je le
rencontrais hier c'est nicole delépine
une femme formidable qui se bat et est
vraiment personne n'en pas quand on lit
tout le monde en parle maintenant en
passant par le récit thierry tu me donne
le la la possibilité de le faire jacques
maître du monde de la semaine le vrai
maître du monde de la semaine c'est mon
ami jean luisi qui l'a d'ailleurs il est
là et oui genre jean genre bêtement
dragon train de boire un coup
j'en m'en cantina rouge quand ils
arrivent ils avaient refait nos maîtres
chez les blacks magie c'est votre enfant
jaillet que c'est un peu narcissique de
dire ça mais ouais je sais je sais moi
c'est moins pas beau mais moi oui ça
fait un petit amas elle commet amaël non
sérieusement non plus dans l'année c'est
un garçon et une fille voilà jean
[Applaudissements]
genre
alors jacques guine mon ami jean louis
dupont n'a pas le monopole de dalhousie
c'est également mon ami mais je m du
monde de la semaine pour jacques dutronc
c'est normal oui maître du monde c'est
énorme
là un autre ici à vous êtes deux là avec
jean marie messier là vous êtes et deux
maîtres du monde de la semaine pour le
moment vous restez vous reste et on
voulait jouer on a de la chance ils
n'ont ensuite pas parce que tu peux tu
veux ça n'est pas très connu du grand
public pour rappeler que jean était un
des premiers serial killer en france et
qu'il a 4 ans francis heaulme qui l'a 99
crime à son actif et qui prépare le son
chef-d'oeuvre le 100e et continue voilà
et tu peux dire chose voilà ce qui a
vraiment bouleversé sa vie dans ton
boulot c est l invention de la nike air
way ou vraiment elle a pu égorgé à tire
larigot sans se faire repérer en face et
on va
avec voudrais donc évidemment vous savez
quand même le handicap que vous infligez
à cet enfant c'est un garçon une fille
un petit garçon amaël l'échappée
embarquée prochaine c'est sûr
en même temps un malaise jean marc est
maître du monde de la semaine dans la
ligne de ce que disait
jacques moi je trouve que il ya un petit
inconnu aussi qui est pas mal lancement
c'est le père noël ouais c'est le maître
du monde de la semaine très bien assez
généreux car dit il je vais laisser
filer les gens petit vote par oui bah
oui je vous laisser filer parce qu'en ce
moment ça répète sec
joyeuses pâques hein c'est juste après
noël la pièce de jean poiret aux
variétés à partir du 16 janvier merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci d'être venus
bien j'ai un km à bord une jeune
romancière j'accueille ann scott
à
[Musique]
didier tu es merveilleux voilà quand on
entend bien les basses après tout c'est
génial bravo continues comme ça tu iras
loin bien en scope bonsoir donc vous
publier un roman qui s'appelle le super
star c'est votre deuxième roman c'est
chez flammarion
voilà c'est pas chez vivendi enfin
marion été racheté par rizzoli
donc je fais chez rizzoli voilà alors
vous avez vous savez comment on fait bah
vous allez le faire si vous savez
comment on fait attention ni jean jean
vas-y attention sur un temps sur un deux
trois
vient alors le pitch basse et je fais le
pitch après bourse devraient si vous
voulez donc c'est la dernière histoire
home ou sexuelle d'une fille qui passe
du côté des mecs c'est une façon de
résumer ça hein
alors c'est autobiographique un argent
qui fait pourrir sans arrêt comme ça on
sait d'ores et déjà c'est au moins le
mérite de faire rire jacques dutronc oui
non ce n'est pas autobiographique si un
petit peu oui
donc l'histoire c'est louise l'héroïne
s'appelle louise elle hésite entre un
guitariste rock qui s'appelle ni qu'ils
aient une dj techno qui s'appelle alex
c'est pas aussi sam c'est l'histoire
d'une fille qui viennent pas qui est qui
et hétérosexuels à la base et qui vient
de passer dix ans dans un milieu techno
est homosexuel et qui un matin se
réveille et envie de retrouver les mecs
et la musique rock que l'écouté avant
voilà il ya une situation récurrente
dans votre livre c'est la fille louise
est obsédé par l'idée de s'acheter un
mac morning et ça m'a bien fait rire le
mcs morning je dis vous avez jamais chez
mcdo vous voulez vous voulez rester en
fille
le mcs morning ses services jusqu'à 11
heures du matin
mais là l'héroïne de hunt scott
évidemment elles arrivent généralement
trop tard et vous savez qu'il ya un
chanteur et midi
ma forme il a terminé avec le voulait
dit c'est fini
venez avec moi quoi les voir ailleurs si
j'y suis rappelez moi quoi bon le patron
n'est pas là je ne peux pas dire que je
voudrais donc c'est lui qui s'est
inspiré de vous vous qui vous êtes
inspiré nuit wall e ou alors le problème
du mak morning à partir de midi il y en
a plus c'est un vrai problème
existentiel pour tout un tas de gens je
le sais pas non c'est juste le problème
ne pas pouvoir pouvoir faire ce qu'on
veut quand on veut je crois licenciés
vous l'a pas là elle était leur bouge et
on bouge pas pendant le jingle ont fait
ça pendant la voilà c'est pas grave je
vais faire lecture pour tout cela je
vais dire à un extrait de votre livre
non mais j'ai pris un extrait savent pas
rassurez vous j'ai pris le plus soft
passage combien page 59
je suis j'ai fait mine de la vouloir à
quatre pattes
sauf moi c était ma gueule la sas est en
train de passagers + porno du bouc l'an
passé le plus soft
en même temps si tu as raison
salma et pourquoi on en est là c'est pas
du tout ce qui se passe avant la page 59
alors elle est en train de se poser des
questions sur les filles des garçons est
en train de repenser aux garçons et à ce
moment là il ya une 6e ex qui revient et
qui est très égoïste et qui revient
temps en temps avec elle juste pour
coucher avec elle et qui la laisse
tomber après est donc un moment où elles
couchent ensemble mais elle se venge
j'ai fait mine de la bouilloire à quatre
pattes elle se retourne et je me suis
affaissé sur son dos et elle a compris
trop tard que j'avais le gold qu'il
était sous le matelas comme avant et oui
ce genre d'habitude ça se perd pas je
n'ai eu aucun mal m la tâche et sans
qu'elle bouge mais dans ont immobilisé
sa colonne le temps d'enduire le gode de
gel puis du bout du pouce j'ai commencé
à jouer avec l'entrée de son anus y a
rien d'extraordinaire
j'avais tranquillement attendre qu'il
lui revient qui lui devient intolérable
de se sentir vide c'est une très belle
j'avais tranquillement attendre qui lui
deviennent intolérables de se sentir
vide
elle savait que pour y avoir droit
elle devait le demander elle devait oser
le dire à haute voix
c'est ce qu'on vit tous les jours elle a
tourné la tête
je n'entendais rien et ça a été mon tour
de la gifle est allé chercher et lundi
que je devais le faire que je devais
l'enculé bordel alors j'y suis allé un
cours de larache en une brève plein
depuis de nouveaux plus rien je retenais
ses mains pour l'empêcher de se toucher
et gérer carrément deuxième phrase
intéressante du passage elle devait
avoir une prostate pourrait baisser à ce
point c'est pas possible autrement
voilà alors ça c'est la page 59 alors
bâche 160 264 non ça c'est un truc n'en
attendait là je vais pas dire c'est
cette histoire d' asphyxie
en gros c'est pour raréfier l'oxygène
qui arrive au cerveau et ça décuple le
plaisir
tu veux genre tu me le fait ce soir bon
enfin vos parents l'ont lu le bouquin
est alors ma mère est psy donc c'est pas
toi c'est vrai donc j'allais pas choquer
salle à chaque saut que ça vienne de moi
mais je pense que sinon il peut le lire
et mon père l'a vu on en a parlé on il
ya plus de pudeur donc on parle pas de
ces choses là mais c'est pas un modèle
que un c'est donc la drogue
non mais c'est un bouquin sur la
bioéthique à la bbox du rock'n'roll et
de la drogue c'est pour ça que j'ai
trouvé ça bien ça fait partie du
quotidien des personnages donc c'est des
cris mais c'est pas le propos le propos
c'est vraiment la musique c'est la
différence entre le rock et la musique
électronique et bizarrement dans sa tête
la narratrice associe le rock aux
garçons et la techno aux filles donc du
coup l'héroïne le rock les garçons d'un
côté la techno les ecstasy les filles de
l'autre qu'elle arrive au haut débit
elle se dit comment comment faire pour
avoir de nouveau quelque chose
d'intéressant une fille un garçon une
vraie musique et voilà et c'est tout
mais c'est pas un rêve ni de cluny de
drogue sur les jeunes oui ça arrive sur
les jeunes du cul de la drogue dites moi
alors vos parents votre mère et
psychothérapeute c'est vrai votre père
est dans la pub
vous êtes un enfant de ces des soixante
huitards aux parents
ils ont divorcé quand je suis né donc ma
main oui mon père pas du tout bon non
parce qu un côté enfant de soixante
huitarde en laisser des enfants qui a
été comme ça purifier un peu les thèses
de michel houellebecq c'est à dire des
enfants qui finalement été élevé par des
gens qui manquait de repères non ma mère
oui mon père notaire il est de droite il
joue le jeu n'était pas là il a pu faire
pour vous votre père oui non mais moi je
suis plus je ressemble plus à ma mère
comme un père joe est un produit des
caractères pas culturellement parlant en
tout cas il s'est très vite quand vous
étiez petit elle n'avait pas de contrôle
et donc un sondé sur la laisse faire ça
sera moins grave que si on empêche l'air
encore plus loin ce soir à 14 ans vous
partez à londres quand même oui je suis
revenu à saison ces deux petites dames
pipi au palace à 16 ans on sait jamais
vu on avait fustigé toilettes c'est ça
en fait c'était une combine avec fabrice
pour travail pour rentrer c'était si tu
veux rentrer à l'oeil avec ta bande de
15 x qui attendent dehors je suive un
beau signe à papa en carrière il ya pas
qu adam cacao rythme n'est pas de
progression sociale
à l'époque vous il y ait un petit peu
des rom et vous dites c'était pour les
amis seulement en général je vous dirai
quand on dit de l'hérault c'est pour les
amis parce qu'on n'en veut pas aux flics
mais disons que j'avais j'étais
tellement jeune que personne ne fuyait
quoi quand il ya des descentes de flics
au palace donc qu en fait voilà c'est un
bon plan 17 ans les ben ouais 18 ans
retour en angleterre après vous donnez
mannequin pour galliano viviane westwood
gauthier yamamoto
mais ça vous ça vous gave le métier de
mannequin non je pense que si on a un
plan de carrière et qu'on gagne beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent ça vaut le coup comme
comme tout eu beaucoup d'argent dray
son agent c'est l'abbé pierre les
productions
ouais ça vous gaver le goût de macao
c'est très différent que c'est pas une
carrière internationale comme ça moi je
faisais pas la couture par exemple
chauffer que le prêt-à-porter
c'était les années milieu des années 80
donc c'est c'était vachement plus
rock'n'roll quoi voilà c'était londres
surtout donc c'était des journaux des
tirages plus est il dit de faire et tout
ça c'est un truc comme ça donc c'est
beaucoup plus confidentielle et comment
vous avez commencé à écrire alors
il y avait une fille qui était mannequin
qui s'appelait les screeners une célèbre
photo de lester winner qui fait ça photo
sipa l'ajustement et qui est que je
trouvais incroyable et donc c'est devenu
mannequin empressé de la caunette j'ai
commencé à apprendre de la drogue points
si la connaître parce que bon c'est des
connexions j'étais amoureuse d'elle
c'était pas sexuel mais messi juste
qu'elle était incroyable qu elle avait
une attitude fera main chedjou
rock'n'roll will et donc je me suis
retrouvé à partir à londres ce qu'elle
vivait là-bas et un jour une et une
interview il disait qu'il avait
rencontré william burroughs et qu'elle
s'était mise à écrire
ils ont tout de suite je me suis jeté
sur morose ça m'a plu j'ai fait des
passes à des clubs comme lui j'ai montré
sa un éditeur français et qui m'a donné
de l'argent pendant un an des droits
d'auteur d'avancé pour faire un roman
alors vous travaillez beaucoup le style
vous dites j'écris proprement je fais un
travail sur la langue je construis des
histoires je fais de vrais livres vous
cherchez atteindre la rigueur des
romanciers américains sa visite en
france les gens finalement ils écrivent
un peu comme ça ce qui leur passe par la
tête vous un peu les horaires de bureau
quoi ces 8 heures à 8 heures
plutôt que de traîner dans les cafés à
saint germain avec un stylo un carnet
moi je suis romancière je suis pas un
homme dans la famille de l'écrivain il
ya tout et je crois que le romancier
c'est quelqu'un qui raconte des
histoires et c'est tout donc moi aller
m'asseoir au flore écrire à la main j'ai
pas besoin d'être inspiré par le fantôme
de simone de beauvoir ou hemingway suis
pas du tout là dedans quoi je suis pas
du tout
jeune auteur parisien qui traînent dans
les cafés qui prend des notes qui se
balade avec faut tenir sur loire aspect
tout mon truc
ouais c'est un boulot mais sur wii avec
le bescherelle sur la table c'est un
métier vraiment sérieuse
vous avez pris beaucoup de dos que vous
en prenez toujours plus depuis 10 ans en
voyant fait dix ans s'appelle que votre
dépanneur à bord c'est fini alors vous
êtes clean la saison 2 c'est dur
d'arrêter nos jours on a envie d'arrêter
on arrête je pense que toutes les fois
où on arrête que ce soit dans les
cliniques où tout seul et des poneys des
produits de substitution n'a pas très
envie qu'un jour on en a marre on a
envie de faire quelque chose à sa vie on
arrête et d'alcool les remplacer la
drogue par l'alcool je bois pas vous
avez remplacé la drogue par quoi c'est à
bien mais le sexe amoureux toujours je
suis pas danseuse dans la ville rose
je sais c'est lamentable mais c'est le
sais que c'est bien alors vous savez
qu'on ne bouge pas par un jingle alesi
allez-y
[Musique]
bien est-ce que vous êtes lesbo nom vous
est hétéro finalement je crois
finalement vous ai découvert qu après
tout vous étiez terreau mais je l'étais
à la base j'ai fait un petit détour par
grand détour de 10 ans mais ses récentes
c'est devenu une parenthèse route voilà
et vous revenez maintenant à
l'hétérosexualité
ouais ça vous plaît vous avez un maître
l'a sérieusement
ben alors lancé un appel c'est que ça
marche c'est que larusso prenons larusso
par exemple la reçoit lancé un appel
dans cette émission la trouvent injuste
s'appelle fabrice est très bien grâce à
l'émission grâce à la multitude de
lancer un appel plusieurs pensent que de
moi voilà je prenne la jeannot c'est
qu'ils les ago alors évidemment est ce
que vous êtes tous trou oui c'est vrai
ça peut être être un peu stressée
annonce on sortait de chez vous ouais ce
que j'étais en plus agoraphobe et qui
vous et déco et bien j'allège sur
trottoir d'en face il y avait une
épicerie dont je n'y suis né pendant un
an et je t'ai truc super cher je peux
pas sortir jusqu'à ce qu'on me dise que
si ça continue il allait falloir
m'interner parce que je peux pas aller
chercher mes cigarettes et j'ai eu peur
est là
ce sera bon voilà je suis soigné tout
seul tout sera fini mais c'est gérable
mais là ça va la règle en calmant est ce
que vous êtes nympho je crois pas je
sais ça veut dire quoi
bah non soumis à une info magnifique a
besoin de beaucoup d'hommes beaucoup de
rapports sexuel ce jour pour le rapport
lui même juste pour l'acte et non non
vous êtes mito n'ont plus d'excusés
sûrement complètement question a touché
la queue devant dinosaures que je ne
crois pas tant le mec il vient et toi et
monfils et dinosaures de gaston ça quand
même
ils viennent pour l'accueil de mon
dinosaures enfin sexy de tous et allez
zou est parano ouais maso certainement
j'aimerais bien qu'on me fasse mal
physiquement quand on fait l'amour je
veux bien qu'on vous parle nous avons
non ça dépend de la personne ça ne sert
à rien si un autre qui monte ça fait pas
de mal mais je sais pas besoin de ça
vous êtes gérant taux pardon géronto
quand on aime les yeux pas jusqu'à
maintenant vous êtes zone coke aux noms
n'ont pas les moyens énormes totaux
est ce que vous êtes à d'amour mais on
ne sous-estime vachement un amour donc
vous êtes adam oui je vous êtes métro
boulot dodo
non non vous êtes disco voit la super
star ami scott c'est flammarion bien
alors maintenant je vais accueillir sa
peine sept ans
quand
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
non
ja
oh
bienvenue donc voici votre album qui
s'appelle seul
attention les mains garraud vous
connaissez le principe
très bien donc seul enfin pas vraiment
seule en fait parce que il ya plamondon
qui a écrit les paroles
il ya musou mara qui a fait la musique
le management c'est rené angeli qui est
le mari de céline dion
vous l'avez enregistré à londres à new
york à los angeles
vous la péter pas un peu en ce moment
quand même là avec tous et tout s'est
fait autour du berceau ça ça va quand
même parce que bon c'est arrivé
tellement vite mon jeu me lasserai péter
du temps de notre dame de paris
ouais vraiment temps que je m'arrêterai
là vous êtes tout seul après à l'époque
y avait d'autres gens avec vous là bas
non seulement elle comme si disons les
plamondon mousse et plein d'autres gens
qui ont travaillé sur l'album on n'est
plus tellement seul bien alors c'est un
succès cet album non bah c'est bien
parti déjà à un mois cinq semaines je
crois on est à 200 milles ou enfance
puis plus on est déjà platine au québec
au québec oui bien sûr c'est tellement
utile québec quand les platines on joue
bien alors écoutez vous êtes derrière en
france derrière youtube et florent pagny
puis ça monte encore alors ça s'appelle
seul
salut
voilà seul par garou il ya un problème
attendez je regarde c'est pas chez
universal ceux-ci là il ya un souci
audrey marnay vient de signer pour 12
longs métrages et hollywood quatorze
albums messier il est royale et du dropt
voulez vous remettre à la chanson
sérieusement là je vais voir ça vous
avez le plus grand groupe du monde
derrière ça va bien alors alors il ya eu
un problème quand même faut en parler à
un vous connaissez cette émission c'est
un peu comme jean marie messier
d'ailleurs c'est l'antique langue de
bois ici c'est à dire qu'il ya un
problème sur une chanson qui va être
criminelle oui il ya une association qui
s'appelle la voix de l'enfant qui a
parlé d' incitation au crime alors mais
vous dites de quoi il s'agit d'une
chanson ou les jeux le disent allez-y
l'armée c'est la relation entre un
adulte et un une jeune fille de 14 ans
quoi une relation c'est un désir qui est
bon chez lolita de nabokov ça existe
depuis 40 ans mais on a dit qu'il y
avait à caveirac dans la chanson mais la
chanson parle pas d'acte est pas tout
simplement d'un homme c'est ça qui
désirent une fidh
il se rend compte qu'elle a 14 ans puis
m'inscris dans sa tête qui est un
criminel
donc il n'a pas le droit il dit écrit
mettez moi derrière les barreaux que je
rêve encore à sa peau 1
j'aimerais justement qu'on l'empêchent
d'avoir ce désir là mais c'est plus fort
que lui l'armée c'est vous le sentiez
qui est d'avoir un problème parce que
sur rtl vous avez déclaré j'espère que
les gens vont pas mal la comprendre
avant que le disque sorte vous vous
doutiez bien qu'elle avoir un problème
moi je suis un interprète manger j'ai
adoré cette chanson là tout de suite
j'ai même parlé avec luc beaucoup
pendant la création
pendant l'écriture du texte jeune
interprète de gens sont mêlés le public
aussi c'est un interprète et interprète
à sa façon
puis on se doute bien que va interpréter
de plein de façons de ce fait il y en a
qui ont mal compris
on sent face à issy régler l affaire
ouais ça parce qu'une association il
avait demandé que l'album la chanson
soit retirée de l'album 1 1 c'est fini
ça mais ils ont été gentils ils ont dit
que l'album
ils ont ils ont aimé l'album
c'est bien c'est tomber les associations
ouais on devrait peut-être leur faire un
album de 13 titres 1 courue la wii vient
donc l'affairé rigueur n'en parle plus
probable voilà tout le monde en parlait
alors donc vous appeler pierre garand
vous êtes né à sherbrooke à 1h30 de
montréal
vraiment vous étiez un élève modèle en
primaire et à 14 ans vous pétez des
plans à 14 ans tout bascule vous faites
une grosse grosse crise d'adolescence
garde et voilà vous monter un groupe de
rock
et alors vous chanter les chansons des
beatles alors vous faites la voix de
paul mccartney c'est un truc qu'on voit
c'est que la voie que vous avez à ce
moment là oui c'était avant oui parce
que sinon c'est plutôt la limite lennon
mais pas macartney mais c'était c'était
le premier groupe qui s'appelait qui
s'appelait when the hundred cette
décomposition et on faisait des chansons
des beatles et j'étais plus guitariste
n'est pas vraiment le chat le lead
singer est d'accord et je faisais les
voir à quelle époque vous avez changé de
voie émue et j'ai commencé les bars
après ça parce que bon c'était le groupe
à 14 ans 14 15 ans après j'ai arrêté
j'ai jamais pris ça au sérieux à 19 ans
par hasard je me retrouve à chanter dans
les bars et
avec un petit peu d'être de toutes les
consommations possible a fait ça quand
les cigarettes la voix ouais pas mal ici
à l'époque débarque on vous appelle gare
ou parce que vous aimez la nuit vous
avez un look destroy
non c'est déjà à l'époque justement un
début de crise d'adolescence à partir de
l'âge de 13 ans a beau appeler guerre
garou et vos parents isabelle gareau
maintenant oui comment devrait on dire
souvent comme une image alors vous
bossez un jour dans un bar ça fait le
liquor store et en 97 c'est
extraordinaire c'est un peu comme vous
un c voilà en 97 plamondon débarquer
vous choisi pour être le quasimodo de
notre dame de paris
j'étais là depuis 6 ans dans ce bar
quand même ouais ça faisant fait cinq 5
ans que j'étais dans ce bar là où on
chante à tous les dimanches donc c'est
dimanche 2 mai alors dites moi vous
pensiez rester imaginer que plamondon
soit jamais rentré dans ce bar vous y
seriez encore encore j'espère y
retourner parce que c'était une espèce
de sentiment de liberté
il s'avère aisée mais ce n'était pas une
punition s'est pas encore du tout
d'abord tout il y avait même le côté
expérimental où j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir essayer plein de musiques
différentes
ouais mais ça y va comment ça s'est
passé l'audition avec plamondon et que
de chanter quand ils vous ont demandé de
venir
ils vous ont joué la belle comment ça
s'est passé en fait luc maupas dit au
départ que c'était pour quelle moto donc
me présente à corchia
je crois qu'il avait même pas 10 ans
richard que j'allais là pour que ce
modèle est oui c'est ça c'est elisha
commence à jouer au piano perrin chanter
belle donc il m'a chanté le premier
couplet au deuxième je commençais à voir
la mélodie antalgiques commence à
chanter la partie de fraude au nain est
prêt il s'est arrêté de jouer les photos
soient gardées c'est là que j'ai compris
que licha savait pas non plus pour qui
j'allais auditionnés ils ont changé la
fin ils ont mis dieu que le monde est
injuste et là j'ai vu inscrire quasimodo
et j'ai découvert cette chanson l'avait
aussi découvrir j'ai aussi découvert
quasimodo parce qu'à l'époque vous ne
l'aviez pas très bien qui c'était
et quand vous avez lu le roman vous avez
été saisie par l'ampleur dramatique du
personnage déjà dans cette chanson-là de
clermont est injuste c'est fabuleux
parce que toute sa souffrance sa douleur
et
et bien écrite puis décrite puis ça m'a
fait mal
la première fois que je les chante et
tout de suite j'ai senti autre chose que
je n'ai jamais chanté de même alors bon
on 81,18 vous venez pour notre dame de
paris en 99 or là c'est le grand moment
de la vie de garou vous rencontrer rené
angeli way mort n'est ni harnais et là
tu tombe fou amoureux et light justement
non
tu crois pas si bien dire première
rencontre donc ils se serrent la main
comme ça et il ya eu un courant magique
dans la poignée de main c'est très très
fort parce que on m'avait beaucoup parlé
de lui qu'un très grand businessman
n'est vrai et là je découvrais le côté
humain c'est une rencontre vraiment 30
secondes passent moins je chante une
chanson avec karen mulder sur un plateau
de télé un spécial céline dion à la
sortie du plateau il revenait qui est là
qui nous serrent la main et puis moi je
dois repartir parce que la première de
notre dame à hyères et cette poignée
mais là je sens tout son côté sensible
et humain puis ça m'a complètement
sidérée puis je suis reparti pour la
première je suis parti un peu ébranlé
c'est sûr que quand tu dis aux gens à ta
famille et tes amis
j'ai rencontré angela j'étais très
impressionné je sais pas il s'est passé
quelque chose
ils disent de rester vivant en
communauté quand même le grand manager
et si après la signature et après coup
qui m'a avoué à dire non c'est fou ça la
vie vous êtes vision en toi c'est pas
elle c'est pas ta façon de chanter ou ta
présence sur scène ça a été la première
poignée de main qu'on attendait à la
gare où c'est là que je voulais en venir
du baratin ça le mec il vous dit garou
quand je fais serré la main j'ai senti
quelque chose de très fort c'est pas ta
voix alors une voix formidable c'est pas
ton physique alors c'est plutôt un beau
physique il dit doit pas vous y croyez
c'est un peu naïf saga roucan maintenant
non mais je le verse en dix jours la
piste et il n'était pas question pour
moi de travailler avec lui jamais
oser imaginer ça mais c'est vrai que la
poignée de main je me suis dit waouh
c'est celui là
quelle belle à ses seins c'est pas vrai
qu'un alors depuis tu sais quoi c'est
que ça clique entre vous alors voilà
donc vous êtes aujourd'hui ça marche
très bien pour vous et vous avez 7
cette phrase très touchante vous dites
j'en reviens pas ce qui m'arrive moelle
ti-cul entouré ce petit cul travers de
mes six mois le ti cul entouré de la
meilleure équipe du monde dès son
premier disque c'est vrai que c'est un
peu un conte de fées un peu hein c'est
un peu comme jean marie messier patron
de vivendi universal conte de fées vrai
marne et jean domicile devant la musique
conte de fée pour les filles qui l'a
croisé matelas pour lui bien alors vous
avez chanté évidemment longtemps dans
les bars à nice en juillet 99 vous avez
chanté sur scène un très bon souvenir
pour tous les gens qui vous ont vu avec
votre groupe deuxième groupe
là c'est plus tard the window cd the
untouchables il ya un tas de sa bourse
voilà alors on va vous faire une
interview jukebox si on ne bouge pas
pendant le djing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est conçu des films bien alors
l'interview de boxe est on ne peut plus
simple je vous donne le nom d'un groupe
ou d'un interprète et vous devez sur le
chant interprété une chanson en anglais
scolaire ou de parler on va voir alors
j'ai commencé ça parce que vous avez
chanté ça longtemps au liquor store les
beatles oui la fatigue est là quand je
fais ça va bien tout va bien maintenant
richard merci dieu dieu ordinaire bureau
du cloud
just dance wii semble dakhil smadja
obama joe cocker
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très bien bravo maintenant leurs regards
ou obligatoire vous l'avez fait à nice
en juillet 99 sex machine compliquée
maintenant alors vous avez pas fait
wilson pickett à nice parce qu'il était
là faisait pas osé le faire parce qu'ils
étaient présents dans la salle
il n'est pas là ce soir wilson pickett
votre favorite potanine hightower bien
et maintenant est ce que vous connaissez
de tuning try a little tenderness o weh
césar cette chanson par merci merci
moi aussi
à bord avant
vas-y un truc - crevant etienne daho
vase est d'accord tedo bien j'en arrive
ici je vais vous libérer en tous les cas
merci d'être merci d'être venu merci
d'avoir eu cette franchise
merci et bravo à garons j'essaye bénigne
la paix maintenant
messieurs jacques aillagon
l'ex empereur du monde de boxe et au
léger voici fabrice tiozzo
[Applaudissements]
alors fabrice tiozzo bonsoir bah écoutez
donc samedi dernier à villeurbanne
c'était la cinquième fois que vous
défendiez votre titre de wb à lourds
légers
vous êtes tombés face à virgin hill à
une seconde de la fin du premier round
on va en parler mais d'abord on regarde
quatre boules de cuir pour nous dans la
ligne
on a une galette
par ici
protess de pierre
houleux depuis
gros les siens
le
le kit marais
sigma s'éteint
et dieu sait que je laime mais c'est en
émettant
ce pas de même
au ps de pierre
pour atteindre ton coeur il n'est qu'une
mare
se passe
le thème
car
quatre boules de cuir sur quatre pieds
de
bombarde le plexus en bourse
l'angle du maxillaire
de cuir dans la cage de
crochet jeu lent
image en est
on l'a plus vite quand même par un
mécanicien
c'est comme si je n'avais pas fait le
combat sexy dans une catastrophe
j'aurais préféré qu'il me démolissent
horaires complètement parce que si mme
démoli en plusieurs rounds
après je peux plus je peux mieux
analyser je n'étais pas en forme j'étais
fatigué mais qu'on partait poche c'était
trop lourd ou n'importe quoi là ils ont
une touche bien donc c'est en boxe et
pas d'accident ça j'ai toujours été
contre contre ça sur un combat ça
commence au début et à la fin mai mais
j'ai rien fait je suis pas marqué mais
après le match j'étais l'âge sans me
dire tu payes tu y vas c'est à toi magie
avec gmail aux mauvais esprits quand
même ce qu au milieu du premier rooney
lui met un gros pain dans sa gueule
[Musique]
yeah mais tu étais pas trop confiants
dans nos salons problème non non non non
parce que j'ai fait des combats trop
trop confiants aider à gagner est donc
faux au jour d'aujourd'hui il faut que
je me pose les bonnes questions à
trouver les bonnes réponses et où est-ce
que c'est pas le fait d'avoir fait
seulement seize reprises en trois ans et
contre des mecs enfin moi j'évite corde
avec son pack un peu de second couteau
quand même est-ce que c'est pas le fait
d'un non le problème c'est que peut-être
c'est l'un des problèmes c'est que je
boxe passé ouais c'est ça que je boxe
passer maintenant que je boxe et ségala
et son numéro deux du nouveau 4 mondial
ouais bon je veux dire je peux pas non
plus sur le numéro un general tulle et
bah ouais ouais ouais mais disons que là
les erreurs qui ont été commises et bien
devant un gars comme ça on les paie quoi
et puis voilà sur la tournée par entre
états et tous les voir le film non
seulement il faudrait faire ça dans le
vide et je voulais voir tout le monde en
parle sauf qu'ils avaient le téléthon
dont tu es rentré pour rien rétablit
bien alors en sortant du ring tu as dit
j'arrête et puis après tout dit j'arrête
plus fait quoi ça va c'est à passer quoi
ça a été un petit moment de nombreux
c'est vrai que la première pensée bien
sûr moi je vais je voulais passer de
poids lourds je voulais bateau les
filles je vais devenir un peu de monde
des poids lourds
et c'est vrai j'ai confiance quand on
perd comme ça avant il ya tout ça qui
tombe et moi je te parle de la boxe pour
être deuxième mais pour perdre en 2002
59 c'est vrai que ma première pensée
c'est d'arrêter après c'est vrai que 3 4
minutes après bon ça va mieux je
commence à avoir les boules
alors maintenant voilà le digère est par
nature bat arrêter maintenant on va voir
une troisième manche parce que ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que le virgin hill et
avait battu en 93 et puis pendant des
années comme ça tu revoyait le combat en
plus et c'est pour ça que c'était chiant
parce que c'est vraiment un truc qui
taraudait un peu l'esprit puis en plus
là sa victoire 93 c'était une décision
des juges
enfin qui s'était pas beaucoup quoi
c'était pas c'était pas un cas au moins
ou non plus j'avais fait un jeu est fait
un bon match par contre c'est pour ça
que cela prend même si j'ai deux
défaites c'est la première vraiment à
gérer parce que la première j'avais
perdu mais j'ai fait tellement un bon
match à cette époque-là contre un grand
champion et moi qui étais rien à quoi
c'était comme une victoire là
claire là c'est une bonne démarche donc
voilà donc il y aura une troisième
manche je pense que non tu vois rien de
frais non pourquoi
mais john king il est d'accord un wii
nommé virgin hill aussi incliné oui
m'enfin midi c'est le monde de la boxe
cissé au dakota prennent ce qu'il faut
que tu t'en fou non ouais et alors tu
penses pas qu'il y aura de troisième au
bacon verte une île non je pense prendre
c'est le seul qui t'a battu deux fois
parce que sinon race est le seul qui m'a
battu 1-1 si je termine rousse moi de
rouler entre 1,8 alors lui lui ce qu'il
a dit virginie l'a dit j'ai été surpris
de gagner si vite
non non non non mais c'est vrai que
c'est un combat qui aurait duré beaucoup
plus longtemps ça va être un match
d'aujourd'hui
bagard une guerre est gagnée comme ça
c'est vraiment il m'aime moi si je sais
j'avais gagné en haroun sera arrêtée ce
en prenant un peu et puis voilà que tu
vas faire alors me reposer bien
réfléchir et puis recommencer
[Musique]
alors jacques dutronc je vous salue je
rappelle le titre de votre livre pensées
répliques je crois que tous les gens qui
ont assisté à l'interview de jacques
dutronc tout à l'heure on a envie de
l'acheter parce que ce ne sont que des
aphorismes des formules du début à la
fin c'est chez cherche midi éditeur
jaloux
à bientôt et merci en tous les cas les
salutistes longtemps
jacques dutronc d'accueil maintenant
marco de fff ça
ok ok j'ai dit ok j'ai dit de laisser
bien à la fin et tout l'or là maintenant
c'est quoi ça va pas mal ça a bien alors
marco prince
c'est votre vrai nom de fff c'est votre
titre de noblesse alors ffc fédération
française de funk
alors moi je suis un peu j'avoue
franchement un peu devait aussi un je
connais georges clinton je connais
funkadelic je connais par la main c'est
quoi le sphinx qui est un mélange de
rythm n blues à la base de roc est assez
épicé comme ça ouais avec des icônes
emblématiques comme james brown george
clinton
sly stone jeu les hommes aussi
ça tombe bien il est devenu complètement
fou et sac à bord ouais
pour cet album là on voulait faire des
trucs avec lui on a rencontré parce
qu'on connaît plein de gens aux états
unis ce qui est le fun c'est une grande
famille
il était tribu un côté club un peu lent
mais ouais on aime bien se promener que
ces dossiers que sur sprint ses deux
premières parties de clinton exactement
l'a fait il nous a ouvert l'europe comme
on dit on a fait sa première partie dans
toute l'europe et on a pris le pire et
le mieux ce qu'il faut pas faire et ce
qu'il faut faire en scène mais alors
dans l'oeuf un qui a un côté glitter il
ya deux ans les gens s'habillent un peu
comme ça afin qu'un délit qu'il ya un
peu de ya les paillettes
ouais mais de la paille et ouais c'est
clair c'est glamour un bain
ouais c'est la musique festive on peut
parler de choses terribles de comme nous
le fait d'ailleurs on parle de justement
oui j'en ai parlé de ça c'est à dire
qu'en fait ça parle du sida ça parle du
chômage ça les paroles d'ailleurs vous
êtes venu vous aussi se dire qu'au début
fff faisait des paroles peut-être avec
un peu moins de sens mais maintenant
quand on écoute ce disque là d'ailleurs
on va le pas l'écouter montvalent
regarder voilà attention c'est comment
on fait marco oui on fait comme ça
marianne est exact attention on est prêt
tu le fais pas tu bien alors le dernier
album que je viens d'entrer s'appelle
vierge donc le single alors va écouter
le single
[Musique]
fait l'album s'appelle vierge et le
single s'appelle le yaourt c'est ça
ouais ces chanteurs yaourt c'est pour ça
c'est venu un yaourt
très honnêtement c'est venu aussi pignon
yaourt c'est venu aurait alors dit qu'on
appelle le yahoo
voilà que ce que tout commence par le
yaourt est donc tout finit par ça aussi
ça soit 16 développe mais oui oui
c'était une chanson il y avait comme ça
commencerait comme mon rôle à moi comme
ça à 30 km du lavabo dia ou bien alors
marco votre père et béninois votre mère
et togolaise avait grandi en banlieue
parisienne et à 16 ans j'étais en
terminale si ce n'est pas malin il y en
a beaucoup ici qu'ils apprennent matelas
les africains sont à s'écarter c'est
vrai que c'était assez bon en maths et
puis bon c'est pas le cas toutes les
matières mais en maths ça allait ouais
et voilà et c'est là que marco découvre
le monde de la nuit mais là messieurs et
là après la vie normale n'était plus
possible
c'était terne comme elle nous l'avait
rencontré le monde de la nuit palace
donc d'abord barman au palace ensuite dj
aux privilèges
en fait au départ ça ce n'est pas du
tout votre vraie vocation ses cinémas en
fait
disons que vous mangez bien ouais mais
ça ça me branche est assez dans mes
rêves d'enfant c'était ça le truc je
vous les médias et tous et puis j'ai
rencontré un copain qui s'appelait
nicolas baby qui est donc devenu
bassiste de ce groupe
entre temps qui lui était dans une école
de comédiens qui s'appelait sécher rôle
à nanterre et il
me demander de faim je m'incruste est
comme comme j'ai toujours su le faire
dans les fêtes et dans les voilà et donc
je vais avec lui quelques fois comme ça
a été ça et puis j'ai rêvé à ça on rêvé
à ça tous quoi parce qu'il y avait
quelques en étaient quelques-uns vous
étiez fan de patrick dewaere c'était
jacques de bankolé votre pote il devenu
quoi isaac de bankolé il vit aux états
unis mais je vais interviewer exactement
recoller dans l'une est là mais j'ai
plus revu ben ouais mais il n'y a pas
tellement de travail pour les comédiens
noirs en france donc il s'est dit ça je
vais être malheureux comme une pierre
soit je vais travailler aux états-unis
c'est ce qui fait oui c'est vrai
qu'après black mic mac vous avez cru
tous que y allait avoir du boulot pour
le pôle est comédien noir et en fait
malheureusement ça vient simplement je
l'attends bien c'est ce qu'on va faire
l'ajustement mois passés au blind test
[Musique]
bravo à mme scott madonna
la vie
elle est bien cette chance album il y
bien l'avenir wake si c'est bien lui de
l'album est bien mais elle est
incroyable d'un tel bide à celle qu en
promo en ce moment il est bien bien donc
ça fait un poids important de ce code
vous comptez 1 mes enfants donc c'est
basé sur la musique il ya toujours ça
peut vous aider
il ya toujours musique dans le titre de
la chanson voilà un comme ça audrey wadi
pas bon enfin bon allez on continue
didier france gall
c'est
non messieurs
alors les enfants la gare où marco polo
à payer la chanson numéro 3 à l'idée
mais bon
rabelais
on signale bravo da phoque
non ce n'est pas seulement la serbie
même score
[Musique]
et voilà
il va
[Musique]
la baisse sur les toits jumelles
c'est le
j'avais dit qu'elle est plus
musique dans le titre à chaque fois
c'est la musicale c'est patrick juvet on
continue chanson numéro 7
chanson de chuck berry interprétée ici
madame ardisson sous votre contrôle par
dans par les beatles bravo laurent
baffie alors là non c'est une chanson de
chuck berry effectivement c'est rock'n
roll music
là c'est un peu plus compliqué de me
donner l'interprète l'interpréter
l'interprète toujours bien sûr je pense
que vous allez faire - le mariole
laurent baffie attention baffie cat and
scott 2 attention didier
quick vikings
8,5 milliards d'eur
bah oui non la chanson s'appelle post
musique bien sûr
[Musique]
yariv leader
les publics
non
elle
[Musique]
très compliqué
très compliqué la chanson s'appelle pop
music effectivement l'interprète
s'appelle m
mais ce n'est pas le fils et qu'il avait
dit viens viens à mon garçon vient
[Applaudissements]
t'appelles comment on parle dans mon
micro tu t'appelles comment je m'appelle
cyrille bien cyrille tu es une star ce
soir c'est cool c'est cool on applaudit
syrie bravo d'un dossier est maintenant
mesdames messieurs le super banco
c'est à dire que celui qui va répondre à
cette question à cette chanson qui va
trouver l'interprète de cette chanson
gagnera le blind test même si laurent
baffie et a4 et hans cote à 2 et oui
c'est injuste je le sais c'est comme ça
didier
[Musique]
aretha franklin
[Applaudissements]
marco
stone peines de music et oui les deux
morceaux qui était extraordinaire
il y avait ailleurs ouais ailleurs
ailleurs que tu connais et celle là des
notes de musique sly the family stone
easter wood stock d'ailleurs ça me fait
plaisir que tu aies gagné avec cette
chanson quand tu me fais honte par là
même la fff
merci beaucoup on peut rallumer voilà
c'est étonnant afin qu'haïti à partir du
siège aujourd'hui au théâtre des
variétés dans joyeuses pâques de jean
poiret mise en scène bernard murat avec
caroline silhol barbara schulz et
monique tard baisse le 5 juillet
ouverture dans la grande cour d'honneur
d'avignon avec la pièce de molière
l'école des femmes jean marie messier
j6m points comme présidente vivant dit
salle chez hachette littératures marco
fff fédération française de funk sortie
de l'album vierge et du single le yaourt
ensuite jacques dutronc pensées
répliques au cherche midi éditeur garou
sortie de l'album seul déjà disque d'or
le single ci s'appelle shell concert à
l'olympia les 2 3 4 avril 2000 est
tournée en france à partir de janvier
garon ann scott
mesdames messieurs superstar aux
éditions flammarion
audrey marnay on retrouvera un magasin
prochainement dans les magazines fabrice
tiozzo qu'on espère revoir rapidement
sur un ring laurent baffie dans la pièce
sexe magouille et culture générale soit
de vieux cas
gymnase à partir du 26 janvier faute
bonsoir représentation en janvier je
rappelle aussi l'opération handicap
international
si la collerette à sapin le sac à sapin
voilà c'est souvent du cadre national
qu'à des gens qui font des mines qui
coupe les jambes des plus enfants et des
gens qui essayent de casser les protège
voilà le livre de coluche s'y dévouent à
la logique de coluche
elle est courte mais elle est bonne au
cherche midi éditeur
je le conseille aussi jean-paul les
terreurs virtuel les nouvelles menaces à
l'aube du xxième siècle
voilà merci ben c'était toulon en part
rendez vous la semaine prochaine merci
d'avoir été avec nous tiens
non
[Musique]
j'ai moi même
jamais
m
[Musique]